there's a prohibition going against
ranchers we've lost over i'd say 40 of
our ranch lands where's the ranch land
going billionaires bill gates is
probably one of the biggest names i hear
thrown around around farmland and food
there's videos of him saying you're not
going to eat meat anymore grape seed is
guess what it is it's canola oil it can
be the oil in your car or you can fry
your french fries with it you can look
at our health in the devaluation of our
dollar and the amount of fake
commodities injected into our food
supply it's the same damn chart they're
trying to remove meat from the
children's diet worse in the schools
just leave the kids to [ __ ] alone our
kids 46 of them are obese or overweight
one out of two is going to diabetes
already has diabetes that is a [ __ ]
genocide that's where we say no more all
right guys bang bang i'm very excited
texas slim here in the house uh i think
a great place to start this conversation
about what the hell is going wrong with
the food supply uh it's just how the
food supply works and so if we look at
cattle as an example i know that you
have the beef initiative and i think
that's probably a good place for us to
start right uh there's cattle on a ranch
and somehow
i eat at home
how do we get from cattle on a ranch to
me eating at home and less about the
problems but just like what does that
process look like for those that don't
understand how the food supply works
well you know one thing is called it's
basically daunting to to start off with
but it used to not be daunting as far as
every one of those touch points of our
food supply let's just say pure animal
protein right now okay you know
livestock you know either be beef or
foul or hog whatever it is
pure animal protein has basically been
so centralized now that you have so many
touch points along that market access
that a lot of people don't even even
good intentional people that are trying
to pay attention they don't understand
the complexities of that and that's been
going on for you know several decades
now but the last decade has really
kind of been very um
it's hindered our way of understanding
what food is anymore so that food supply
is getting more complex with more and
more touch points what's driving that is
that like a a capitalism thing where
more people are trying to put their hand
in the cookie jar and extract uh value
is it a regulation thing
i would say basically coming from where
i do as far as agriculture and ranching
it's it's basically been a combination
of a regulatory capture for one and then
people that know how to basically
manipulate the regulations that are put
into place you have some corruption you
have some manipulation you have some
global movements of course that we know
about they all kind of combine in the
last person that's really being thought
of as the consumer and the rancher the
producer
and so to say that it's like you have
this
movement that's been going on we've had
four major food consolidations on the
corporate global corporate level okay
since 1990 to 95 when nafta kind of
kicked in
so saying that they're they're pushing
for a one world food group and they're
trying to basically
compartmentalize the understanding of
food and then actually the market access
of that foods where they can have more
control over our nutrition our food our
access to food from supply chain lines
and i think that's being exposed right
now that it's kind of a broken system
and they're trying to grab even more
control right now as far as the consumer
itself got it so we go to the consumers
uh
in terms of where we are in america it's
like 45 of americans are obese 70 plus
percent are overweight yeah and uh some
of that one out of two is diabetic
insane yeah and and so some of that is
obviously people of a sedentary
lifestyle like you know there's a bunch
of things that feed into it but the food
supply is a huge piece of it and so if
we go all the way back to where this
starts right and we look at these animal
proteins
what are the ranchers doing or kind of
these
initial food supply kind of insertion
points if you will what are they doing
with the food and if we were simply to
go buy it directly from them what would
be the difference between that food
versus once it gets on the other end of
the food supply well what you have now
you have ranchers and that's a broad
spectrum of ranchers or animal producers
right you have cow calf operators you
have you have somebody that brings a
calf all the way to
you know adulthood to where it does get
harvested you know and so they they
steward that animal they steward the
land all the way through
and then you have some uh ranchers and
animal producers that'll take that cow
calf to a certain level and then they
basically have to get rid of it
because the the profits are controlled
the margins are controlled by four major
uh global processors
those processors of course are jbs
national tyson in cargill and so what
happens is that they don't have a say-so
after they sell that cow
once it goes into the form
we call them the packer feeders
processors once they get into that
feedlot apparatus then they're basically
fed grains they're given antibiotics
some of them are given steroid you know
you just don't know
and a lot of that type of input that is
given into that cow is not always
reported to the consumer themselves
that's part of the regulatory capture
you know it involves the fda it involves
the usda so the rancher producer doesn't
have a say in that and they have to go
ahead and get rid of that cow at that
point in time
because they had to have that cow
processed so dumb question but uh on the
animal protein side we've got people who
essentially go birth to like adolescence
right is kind of the way i think of it
and then someone else takes it from
adolence adolescence to adulthood it's a
good way to put it and then from
adulthood okay now we're gonna go give
it to the four processors right and
whatever they do from there they almost
in some way are essentially taking an
animal that
usually one or two kind of ranchers have
uh uh stewarded to use your word to this
point and then from there that's where a
lot of kind of the nasty stuff is
happening and then the animal's
ultimately killed cut up and then uh
sent to a grocery store or whatever for
the consumer 100
and you know what you know i'll give two
kind of comparisons here so we can kind
of clarify
you have the cow calf you have the the
feedlot uh cow you have a commodity
cowboy you know there's a lot of things
that we we basically refer to in the
ranching industry what kind of producer
are you and then you have the
regenerative regenerative basically
means from the soil to the grass to the
cow to the producer
then to the processor then to the
supplier then to our forks
us as the consumers that's kind of a
decentralized vertical integration back
into how we used to basically raise
steward harvest and consume that cow
right now once we get to that processing
point that's the four major global
processors they process over 80 percent
of our animal protein in the united
states right now and they get to have a
big say about what type of cattle that
they are bringing in what type of labels
they can put on our beef let's say like
usda prime that doesn't mean anything
anymore we don't know where that cow is
coming from what did it used to mean it
mean it used to meant that this was u.s
beef that we basically we are the best
cattle producers in the world we have
proven that and it really all started in
texas in the late 1800s and so we have a
protocol that we did know how to grow
the best speed from the world part of
that stewardship part of that basically
harvesting of the animals themselves
the the lands that are used that's all
been kind of globalized and we the
consumer are not understanding of what
has taken place but the ranchers do know
because they're being there's a
prohibition going against ranchers you
know we've lost over i'd say 40 of our
ranch land
in the last you know let's say less than
two decades even even worse than the
last decade itself where's the ranch
land going
billionaires wherever you want you know
whatever so this is like a lot of you
have a lot of people selling out these
days because you know we know real
estate we know land values they're
getting out of the system because
they're having to rely on those
processors their their margins on those
cows are very minimal in the past like
you said if they were able to take that
cow all the way to your fork their
profit margins you know they triple they
quadruple that way they have power now
they don't have a voice a digital voice
or they don't have a voice in basically
the market access that we started this
conversation with so if we go back 1800s
up until i don't know a couple decades
ago uh you mentioned this kind of
decentralized model which was a local
rancher
would be there to raise uh the animal it
would go to a local producer it would go
to a local supplier and then it
eventually would end up on your plate at
your house
and there were a network of these
throughout the entire country
uh and over time what we saw as we've
seen in many other industries but but
this one is important because it's food
that we're consuming there was
consolidation and when you look at that
uh kind of supply
system
the place that the consolidation has
happened and is most egregious is at the
producer level right it's basically
people have gone and they've created
these four uh major producers
now processors uh processors i'm sorry
uh and so if we go back and we think of
let's start with the land first i
remember the first time that i got
tipped off to uh hey there might be a
problem here as i was reading uh ted
turner the founder of cnn's book and uh
quite entertaining you know uh uh
frankly you know kind of a tip of a cap
to an entrepreneur who saw a market
opportunity and said hey i'm gonna go
and i'm gonna build up this whole news
thing and made a bunch of money doing it
he then got into
land ownership and uh i believe is still
today the largest bison owner uh in
north america
and so when you say wait a minute one of
the folks who was an entrepreneur and
you know kind of the equivalent of what
is today the technology industry he was
on the forefront of the media industry
uh what is he doing buying up land and
uh bison now his argument was that
there's going to be this food crisis and
we need to make sure that there's uh
kind of a resurgence of these animals
and and things like that uh if we start
there
how big of a problem uh is that or are
we actually happy that folks like a ted
turner are going up and buying all this
land and trying to create uh such a
larger animal population
no we're it's not a good thing it's not
to consult it's not a good thing to
consolidate
uh basically
the vertical integration that get gave
us the health in which we strive with
whenever you have that major
consolidation of land and of livestock
and then basically of how that livestock
gets stewarded and processed
that is way too much control in too few
hands
and if you if you look back and always
tell everybody look at how your
grandfather used to live maybe it's your
great-grandfather right
but what what my grandfather did is that
he had a farm ranch he stood in land and
in the animal itself
what he did is exactly what you said
he's like okay i'm gonna i'm gonna raise
this cow to a certain level then i'm
gonna go have it processed he fed his
family first and then he fed the
community small texas town let's say
that small texas town had a small
microprocessor
an abattoir well that community said
okay well we have this avatar we have a
butcher we have a grocery store perhaps
and that so that local
produce that local animal was sold to
the local community and it was
decentralized it was a two-party system
it was a peer-to-peer transactional
system that the community basically
agreed to themselves and if you look at
food and where it comes from most people
say you should be eating where you're
standing
food from where you're standing and
that's that's what you know america
basically that's how we got started in
the 1800s
texas fed the nation at some time
basically after 1878 texas started
feeding cattle to the united states okay
why did they do that well you had the
civil war right and then you'd had texas
became a nation then it became a state
and then in texas we had the comanche
wars we had a lot of conflict that was
still gone by 1878 all of that had ended
okay the comanche wars had stopped we
had full access to the state and then
all of a sudden we had all this cattle
that were roaming around the state of
texas and so you created the cowboy
which came from the vicaro from mexico
so you look at that and they say well
wait we have all of this food how are we
going to deliver this food and where are
we going to deliver it to well we had
the railroad that's really started going
east and west and north and south well
then you had the cowboys started the
cattle drive and we started feeding
military bases across the united states
some in the southwest some in the east
it sees cattle drives and the railroad
system itself would deliver this pure
animal protein and then we started
delivering to places like kansas city
chicago new york and we fed a nation at
that time and what i'm doing with the
beef initiative is saying okay we fed
the nation in 1878 that's when this
started we're going to do it again the
way we used to do it because we've been
captured the rancher has been captured
and our basically our consumption models
have been captured in a way that is
nutritionally starving us now you said
something to me uh recently that just
blew my mind which is uh a large portion
of the beef in the united states of
america is not consumed by the american
consumer it's actually shipped elsewhere
yeah
i think that will shock many people who
hear that as it shocked me what is going
on there why why is american beef being
shipped elsewhere and then what does
that mean in terms of the beef that
we're consuming sure well
what i usually do to help clarify that
uh you know you look at how much beef is
imported into the united states and
we'll go back to jbs one of the
processors
okay they've been you know we'll go
we'll we'll cover them a little bit
later but i call it the brazilian cattle
drive you have a you have a cow that
starts on grass in brazil throughout its
life it makes it all the way to mexico
it gets fed grains it gets to america
and then it gets processed and then it
gets to have that stamp of usda prime
put on it well in san antonio i can't
remember exactly the processing center
and i won't call them out because it's
not the smart thing to do
but they did a genetic test on some
ground beef okay well they found that
that ground beef had over
80 sets of genetics in that ground beef
that's 80 different cows was in that
batch of ground beef it's not one cow it
was 80 different cows
okay so that brazilian cattle drive is
part of that
import that comes into the united states
here in texas or in texas what happens
is that's the market access from that
beef from brazil gets spread out to the
wholesale market so texans are eating
actually beef from brazil
africa
other places in the beginning i told you
that you know we grow the best beef when
we harvest the best beef in the world
the united states does a lot of that
definitely comes from texas because of
its history well a lot of that beef is
sold on the global market to the highest
bidder and the ranchers and producers
don't have any control of that it's the
process
processors that are the global
processors packers and distributors
when you say that it's the best beef
help people understand what exactly
makes up the best beef right so if you
were to look at let's say the brazilian
cow versus something here in the united
states what makes it better well you
know you look at technology and we say
oh technology is bad for food no it's
really not i mean we've always been at
the forefront of genetics of knowing how
to raise the right bread of beef you
know you have your angus you have you
know charolais
we used to have the longhorn you have
all kinds of different breeds of cattle
well the united states has always been
at the forefront of understanding you
know certain geographical areas breeds
of cattle so our technology that we we
have invested in the cow itself is by
far the best in the world that's ever
happened
so with that type of technology and that
type of intelligence that we've invested
into the cow itself
well we get to spread that out towards
the world the whole world you know we
get to you know you think china has
basically studied the cow like we have
no but they're getting to buy the best
beef
and so you have that type of apparatus
where we've done all the research and
the development we've done the proof of
work and now these global processing
centers are taking our proof of work and
they're sharing it to the highest bidder
across the united or across the world
and once again we the consumer and we
the rancher don't have a say in that
and because of the regulatory capture
because the amount of global money that
is involved in making sure that that
that highest bidder gets that texas b
for the united states beef yeah so it
makes sense to me that if i am the
processor uh and i basically go to the
global market and i say who who will pay
me the most right for my best product
sure we may not like it but that's just
how economics work that's how capitalism
works right is they're going to go
auction off for the for the highest
bidder what i i don't understand is the
cow or cattle that starts off in brazil
that kind of uh cattle drive if you go
to the united states is there
money kind of to follow and that's why
they're doing it is basically now that
that uh rancher or somebody along that
line they're trying to get ultimately to
the united states and have it processed
in the u.s because they actually make
more money yeah 100 i mean that cow that
comes from brazil
i call them touch points okay okay that
cow from brazil is going to have
probably about 20 touch points before it
hits your fork
okay so how many people made money in
those touch points and a lot of times it
the packer gets to decide that
the processor gets to decide that and
the distributor gets decided that decide
that because they're all the same global
corporation okay if you do a
regenerative ranch or producer basically
you're gonna have two touch points
you're gonna have me and the rancher you
and me the rancher and so if you have
those two touch points who's making the
money okay well you the consumer is
getting a high value quality item that
you know exactly where it came from the
ranchers saying okay instead of 300 off
of this cow i can basically cut this cow
up and make all kinds of cool steaks and
i can actually you know my margins go
from three to four hundred dollars a cow
to maybe two thousand dollars a cow that
money goes back into the land it goes
back into the cow itself and it goes to
the rancher so he can maintain his
legacy
create a you know a pillar of strength
that he doesn't have right now but he
used to have in the beginning but the
global processors took that away
distributed those touch points to other
people making those profit margins you
mentioned earlier that uh ground beef
there's been these genetic tests yeah uh
that it kind of uh it's like a surprise
audit right of like hey what is actually
in here yeah and uh there was 80 uh or
around 80 pieces of genetic information
in there meaning 80 different cows uh
what is the problem for for those that
don't understand in terms of if it was
just ground beef from one cow versus 80
is it complexity and so if any one of
those 80 cows has something wrong with
it got steroids had some sort of
treatment along the way then it kind of
poisons the other 79 or is there other
things to consider well i mean you just
made me think of a kind of a comparison
let's get 80 hamburgers from 80
different fast food joints let's blend
them all up and then let's make a new
hamburger
okay
are you going to trust that hamburger
you shouldn't already because it's
coming from fast food but anyways if you
get that much you know variety within
consumption of food
you really think that that consumption
model is pure do you really think that
that food is pure how many how if you've
got 80 different cattle in a ground a
pound of ground beef
how can you track down the complexities
of what could go wrong with that beef
and how many chemicals are in that beef
what have they included into that beef
to make it to where you think it's it's
usda prime well there's a lot of
unknowns there right and if you are
basically eating a random consumption
model well that your health is random at
this time
so we talked a little bit about ted
turner obviously going and consolidating
farmland um and we've talked a little
bit about uh the processors getting this
kind of four companies that really have
created uh somewhat of um a
monopoly on the market across those four
players
bill gates is probably one of the
biggest names i hear thrown around
around farmland and food um
let's start with the farmland purchases
that he's made i think he is the single
largest landowner in all of uh farmland
farmland yeah in north america
is
it's just hey nobody should have that
much farmland and so that's the problem
or there are other things to consider uh
when i hear people talking about bill
gates i wouldn't say because we live in
america i mean you can you know if you
can afford it you should be able to own
it and steward it right
well with his actions and what he does
on a global scale you know you can look
at he's got so many shell companies uh
cascade investments i think is is his
investment company that goes in his llc
where he can go and acquire all this
land
and if you look what he's trying to do
at this particular time you know i think
he's got investments in yeah i don't
know
from five to 13 fake meat companies
and so you look at what his narrative is
and basically what his intentionalities
are you know you're looking at him
basically taking animal protein out of
the american consumption model and he's
he doesn't hold back he said this is how
we're going to eat
you know there's videos of him saying
you're not going to eat meat anymore
you're going to eat this vegetable
protein
and we know it doesn't actually
we've got the texture down we've got the
look down it doesn't quite taste the
union like it should be like you desire
but we're almost there so you will be
eating this and so if you look at what
his intentionalities are it is to own as
much land as he can and to not let it
basically steward animals in the way
that got us here so the concern is if he
buys up let's just use the extreme
example if he bought up all the farmland
in america and he was the sole farmland
owner uh he could on a whim say we're
not going to do this anymore now these
other companies that i have invested in
that are making kind of genetic
engineered
meat which again isn't meat but uh is
being positioned that way
he essentially would be able to cut off
the supply of uh of kind of the
traditional animal proteins and then
force people to adopt this new
genetically engineered one 100 percent i
mean what's if you if you kind of look
around and you know if you're on twitter
bitcoin twitter you see a lot of things
that are happening well you know all
these processing centers that have gone
up in flames okay and i keep on saying
we're going through a global industrial
food shift well what does that mean well
from the ground level the industry is
changing and he's part of driving that
model of the global industrial food
shift well you look at processing
centers i once again i say that and you
look about probably since especially the
last 10 years but especially since 2017
and 2018 one of the biggest investors in
new processing centers that do not
include the animal themselves they're a
new form of processing center are the
processing centers themselves jbs tyson
national and cargill well if those guys
are processing all of our animal protein
okay and they're building new processing
centers that will actually take the
animal and the soil out of those
processing centers and go to even more
ultra processed food model well bill
gates is locked step and barrel with
them at the same time and that's part of
the global industrial food shift that
we're seeing and we've seen those in our
time we've seen we saw them after 1971
you know what the f happened in 1971.
well the dollar got debased well our
food got debased and when it got debased
they introduced new fake commodities
into our consumption models that's
what's happening with bill gates what is
their argument right so if i was to go
talk to gates or somebody else and i
said hey why are you doing this climate
change okay climate change is like a big
driver okay explain more in terms of
like what argument are they making
around climate change well of course if
you look at climate change and how it's
always been manipulated for certain
reasons you know i've i've grown up you
know i'm generational x first we were
going to freeze to death now we're going
to burn to death you know it's always
some type of decade type of psyop that
they're doing within you know our
understanding of what climate change is
what they've done now is they're looking
at carbon you know they're looking at
you know carbon hazards what is causing
this climate change well it's too much
carbon
but what they're really not telling you
is that the soil has been destroyed by
the chemicals in which what we've been
using especially in the last 50 years
since 1971.
and so what they do is they create a
narrative they keep they they create a
global marketing plan saying well
climate change is because of cows and
now you know on the u.n
basically platform and as far as the
globalists they do consider the cow a
carbon hazard is that because of cow
forts is that is that well it's actually
called calpers but
yeah farts sound better than birds
methane you know and everything like
that exactly but what you know that's
once again they they exploit ignorance
of of the cow itself and so that's a
distraction that they get the public to
look at saying oh my gosh
i'm not going to eat beef anymore i'm
going to be a vegan because the cow is
bad for the planet and i want to be a
good steward of the planet
what is insane to me i read a study
previously and we can link to it which
stated that if you give cows in their
feed uh seaweed yeah it will drastically
reduce the methane output and so cow
farts burps etc uh drastically reduced
and so let's just say on one side of the
extreme you have like let's not touch
cows anymore let's move to you know
genetically engineered food uh let's all
go vegan and essentially abandon what
humans have done for literally centuries
yes uh-huh
instead why don't we just figure out how
to make them stop burping or farting
well it's not the issue though that's
the problem
see we're we're validating what they're
making up as the is the propaganda that
has nothing to do with what's going on
with climate with carbon explain what
you think is going on what's going on is
we've killed the soil okay in what way
with herbicides and pesticides the
chemical companies from
you look at after world war ii and we'll
kind of
build into what's going on right now
okay globally on a macro level after
world war ii what we did is we quit
making bombs we started making
fertilizer okay and it was a good thing
it's like hey we got this nitrogen we've
we can actually make these plants grow a
lot faster they're you know they can
battle droughts they can do a lot of
things and so it started out very with
well intentions
and we we did they went out to the
farmer like will harris with white oak
pastures and we're having a conference
there a summit but he told me a story
about his father a guy shows up and he
had a bunch of fertilizer he goes i'm
going to pour this on your your crop and
i'm not going to pour it on this part of
your crop and i'm going to come back in
about you know a week and then we're
going to talk again well within that
week that crop had grown exponentially
more it got all this really good
fertilizer and all of a sudden we were
on to something as a nation and what who
was driving that was the chemical
companies okay
and so as we've evolved in time in 1971
we still had the micro farms we still
had my grandfather that stewarded land
fed his community eric butts the ag
commissioner under nixon came out and he
said guess what we're going to go big or
you're going to go home
and what he meant he said you're going
to do one crop and you're going to go
fence defense because we have all this
new technology of chemicals basically it
was the herbicides the pesticides the
fertilizers and so then they said we're
going to feed the world and we're united
states of america we have won and we're
going to show everybody it was part of
battling russia and communism it's like
we we do need to sustain our communities
and and we need to help out the rest of
the world great let's do it right well
they have failed and how they have felt
is that by doing that and by doing this
high production model of monocropping
our food they've basically destroyed our
soil to where we have to genetically
modify our seeds more we have to use new
chemicals to make those plants grow and
we can't rely on the soil like we did
from the beginning so if i try to break
this down
in the most elementary way sure it
started out with the seeds that you
would
put into the soil were those seeds that
we'd been using for heroin
and the idea originally was take the
fertilizer put it on top of the seeds in
the soil and we would get a more
efficient harvest right and it would not
only be more efficient in terms of time
but also the
output could be more from an actual
aggregate amount and so if we're getting
more harvest in terms of frequency
and larger harvest each time obviously
that seems amazing right there's more
food it's more plentiful all this stuff
uh
but it didn't stop there no and then
this is where we get okay well if we put
fertilizer we get you know x amount of
uh of improvement what if we then start
to try to address quote-unquote problems
so this is where the pesticides and
herbicides come in explain a little bit
more in terms of what was the original
thought process behind introducing those
and then what is you know kind of with
hindsight bias on our side like what is
the analysis as to whether those have
been good or bad or what is the impact
there
well
you're asking probably you're asking the
right person but you know i look i've
known a lot of people
in the agricultural business and the
dependencies of those chemicals in which
we have stewarded our land our farms our
ranchers it's some evil [ __ ] it
didn't start out being that way but
throughout time you've you've got you
know chemical companies that basically
you know invented asian orange that are
actually in that
invented roundup
which is glyphosate and so you use
glyphosate and you do studies on
glyphosate and you look at you know the
chemical companies that basically
engineer glyphosate well guess what it's
poison to humans it's poisoned to the
ground it's poison and
by saying that the chemical companies in
the beginning once again they were
something that was beneficial but now
you look at how they have changed and
how they've leveraged into everything
that we touch
you know throughout the last 50 years
it's greed 100
and they basically take the
understanding and the clarity of how we
got here the source of the seed of how
we got here they now own it's a power
play you know i wrote the harvest of
deception that first article that i
wrote and you really break down where
does the seed come from where did it
come from in the past
and where is it now well basically our
seed is not the heirloom seed anymore it
is a genetically modified seed that
basically the grain companies and the
chemical companies
own and possess i want to understand
this better because uh in this piece you
specifically talk about something called
a rape seed
and uh from my understanding is that's
what was used for you know decades and
decades if not centuries uh and at some
point it gets banned mm-hmm and 1956 by
the fda for human consumption okay and
now we have these genetically modified
versions
describe a little bit in terms of what
are the differences between the seeds
and why did the fda step in and actually
say hey the seed that we've been using
for so long no longer is allowed for
human consumption
okay the rapeseed let's uh everybody
should know rapeseed is i it's
freaking weed but guess what it is it's
canola oil that's what we call canola
oil is rapeseed 1956 the fda outlawed it
because it was toxic to human
consumption well once again we get into
modifying a seed that creates business
that creates profit profits
okay then once we've modified that seed
into something well
what are we trying to get rid of here as
far as you know big ag the the grain
companies well they're not using the
grass to basically steward animals what
they're doing is now we can we can grow
these grains in a way that we can
actually you know use to feed these
cattle right and so what you do is you
get a chemical company that basically
goes in there and lobbies to say hey
we need to get rid of animal fats out of
our diets and it goes back to the story
of 1954 when eisenhower had a heart
attack
heart attacks really didn't happen but
they needed to find the vic the the
cause of you know heart disease we had a
guy named ansel keys and he came out and
he created a big study and it's it's
basically it was a it was a bureaucratic
kind of uh
uh an attempt to influence lobbyists and
politicians and so they really started
saying that animal fat was bad for you
okay if animal fat is going to cause
heart disease and clog your arteries we
have to have a solution and so they
looked at vegetable oil and they said
okay well how can we make this vegetable
well rape seed grows very easily it's
kind of a weed but it's kind of toxic
let's take out the uric acid okay let's
industrialize this seed in a way to
where we can make it to where yeah i can
run oil it can be the oil in your car or
you can fry your french fries with it
and that's what we've accomplished and
so now that you had the big seed oil
movement that's really really started
taking off once again
1971 we devalued our dollar as a way
that we could devalue our food by
injecting a new fake commodity into our
consumption and it has a lot of
varieties in which it can be used one of
it is they can inject it in candy bars
crackers
hamburger meat
the bonds of a hamburger so now it's
becoming a commodity that is subsidized
by the united states government and so a
lot of farmers will go in there and
basically
farm rapeseed so they can stay in
business so what happened is the seed
itself was a natural thing that had been
used forever uh and then we decided to
still use a type of it it's just one
that we have genetically modified right
uh and
rather than it stay in kind of its
little corner of the world in terms of
its uses we essentially have uh exported
in some way to the entire economy uh and
so much of our food now actually
contains uh all of these oils
and that's how we cook food that's how
we treat certain things i believe that
it's even found in uh various other
types of products that use on a
day-to-day basis and so when you go and
you look at that
how much of
those types of changes around the
genetically modified seeds and uh the
grain that is actually fed to the
animals is then linked to where we
started earlier with 45 of americans are
obese and 70 plus percent are overweight
is there like a direct connection
between
literally the food you're consuming is
because we've genetically modified all
this stuff you bet 100 and it's it's
foolproof now you can
especially you know i always refer to
bitcoin twitter you know there's a lot
of researchers in there and they you
know you'll you'll see these pictures of
people on the beach in 1969 and 1970.
everybody's fit everybody is healthy
everybody's just i mean really
collectively as a group of people you
can see a society that was basically
healthy and at that time we had animal
fats we had pure animal protein we had
access market access to a different food
system in the 70s
if you look at the 70s it's a lot like
what we're going through now we had an
economy crash we had gas shortages you
know you had a lot of prohibition
against certain things well at that same
time is when we did invest
into this new fake commodity system if
you look at 1971 the health of a nation
and you look at the amount of let's say
seed oils that have been injected with
high fructose corn syrup
highly processed foods basically into
our consumption you can look at our
health in the the devaluation of our
dollar and the amount of fake
commodities injected into our food
supply it's the same damn chart yeah and
you can really you don't
it's hard to question it's hard to say
no it's not and you know you brought it
up with you know 70 over 70 percent of
americans being obese and overweight
diabetic metabolic bankruptcy is what
we've got it's only a 50-year window we
weren't like that before 1971. and when
we look at this uh you mentioned fake
commodity a couple of times and what's
so fascinating about it is in some ways
uh people may actually uh understand hey
i'm eating something that is fake right
if you go and try a candy bar or
something it's obvious that that did not
grow in the ground
somebody somewhere along the way made
that uh tastes great but probably not
healthy for you um and so i i
categorized some food as just like it's
very obvious that this is uh
manufactured processed all that uh but
there is a large portion of the
population who actually believes that
they are eating healthy
but what you're really uncovering here
is you may be eating some sort of beef
but it could have come from uh an animal
that was eating genetically modified
seeds and do people know that or is
there any way for them if i go to the
store and i look at uh the beef that i'm
about to buy do they have a big label on
it that says hey this animal is fed
genetically modified seeds no and that's
what's happened you know especially with
the labeling laws and how the fda
basically is a gatekeeper to chemicals
that are injected into our food supplies
and i'll do on two touch points and i
think you and i talked about this
earlier is you know october of 21 last
year basically the fda won a lawsuit and
it's under the grass rule generally
recognized as safe that's what they use
and they leverage
what that means is that the fda can say
hey
you know we've got these chemicals that
we use
in the science of food you know they
love to use the word food science and so
in october of last year they want a
lawsuit to where they can inject
thousands of new chemicals into our food
under the grass rule and they don't have
to tell us what it is
and so labeling laws of course we talked
about gmo well we've all seen it we've
all you know it's always there
genetically modified right that's what
that means well now they've even changed
genetically modified to bioengineered
and it's a barcode on your food
packaging so now they won't actually put
the gmo label on it they instead will be
engineered you have to go actually scan
the barcode yes with like your cell
phone or something and if you scan the
barcode with your so like an app on your
phone yeah then it will tell you that
it's been genetically modified it'll be
bioengineered they're gonna they're
really kicking in the bioengineering
sounds cooler it does yeah it's very
scientific
and so
but you look at that okay and that
happened at the same time fall of 2021
the labeling laws changed and the fda
says sure go ahead and put 000 new
chemicals into the food supply in 2022.
you mentioned the generally
recognized recognized safe yeah
nothing is general when it comes to
regulations oh man that's clown world
stuff man yes so
explain a little bit more what is the
intention of this regulation
i think it's so they can uh confuse the
consumer man why else would they want
and they can inject you think about each
chemical that they get to put into our
food supply okay now let's break that
down as those touch points that we
talked about the cattle that's massive
profit on a global scale that they get
to inject and you become the recycling
bin of that basically of that chemical
that they get to put in there that
chemical could be all kinds of different
things nanotechnology particles who
knows what it is anymore
but by saying that each chemical is is
is basically making profits it has a
budget it has a plan you know and that's
how each one of those chemicals if we
are the recycling bin of those chemicals
it's foolproof
why wouldn't they do it it's business
it's big global business man we're
talking about profits here we're not
talking about nutritional value that's
out the door because
americans don't care about nutritional
value and if they do
eating their best intentions is not
going to get them to health because it's
basically a hamster wheel of people
chasing health anymore
and you have to go deeper you have to
get into a level of food intelligence
that actually has to be more intentional
and it can't be random anymore so if i
go to the grocery store can i eat
food from there sure that is not
genetically modified you can okay but
what i usually tell people and i think a
lot of people hear it don't shop in them
inside out house that's where you should
not be because that's where most of the
processed food lies
shop on the corners shop on the outside
walls where you have your vegetables and
fruits and vegetables and meats in your
dairies and whatever
but you know i don't
very little of my consumption comes from
the supermarkets anymore but i've been
doing this for a while and how i was
raised is this i don't like go you you
go into a supermarket now it looks like
a cartoon world
think about that yes go walk up and go
film it and then go back and watch the
film as you walk down the aisles how
many colors how many animation pictures
do you see
how much manipulation is being fed into
your brains like oh heart healthy and
it's got a you know a wonderful picture
and somebody's very happy and in peace
and you know think about the
manipulation that goes on with marketing
advertising injecting chemicals into
your food supply and you are the person
who gets to recycle every bit of it from
audio to video to the food itself
you are the test subject and they make
you feel good about it because it tastes
good i'm actually shocked that canceled
culture made its way into the grocery
store and they started to cancel some
people uh who were on the boxes right
but but that that happened um so
you go to the grocery store i think a
lot of people here say all right cool i
got it i went last night
screwed up yeah
what do you do when you go you shop
around the edges of the grocery store
you avoid the middle uh what does a
normal diet look like like when you say
that uh hey i'm not gonna give health
advice right everyone's body is
different right but how do you think
about putting body uh food in your body
when you're traveling and not at home
right
i look the source of the seed of my
nutrition is pure animal protein it's
that simple but you know
that's how i was raised we were raised
with we had a freezer full of beef at
any time you had market access to that
beef five years old i'm cooking
hamburgers from a local rancher right or
from grandfather or whatever and so that
is the source of the seed of basically
how i look at food right now especially
in the united states of america it's
like yesterday i went and i got in flew
in and then i went to publix which you
know it's it's a it's a good store you
know there's there's a lot of things
that are good about it and there's a lot
of things that are bad i went straight
to the meat section i bought some
hamburger meat grass-fed i know it
probably probably isn't grass-fed but
it's as close to it as i can find got it
so it's not a black and white issue here
there's so much gray and so i buy that
beef bought a steak bought hamburgers i
went to uh the beachfront i cooked the
steak and hamburgers i ate the
hamburgers last night took me less than
30 minutes same amount of time as people
sit in the freaking drive-through at
mcdonald's and here i ate burgers last
night and i had a steak for breakfast
i won't have to eat again
probably until late tonight if i if i
don't want to
by eliminating all my i think that i
have all these options i don't give
myself options yeah and so when you
go and you're looking at uh kind of the
meat counter if you will right and they
say hey what do you want right are there
things that you will avoid in uh in
there in terms of selecting the meat at
the grocery store and things that you
will go so you mentioned grass fed uh
like almost give people like what's the
framework right if they're gonna go and
they're gonna get meat at the grocery
store what should they be thinking about
and what are the things that they should
avoid
this episode is brought to you by eight
sleep good sleep is a game changer and
the eight sleep pod is the best sleep
machine i sleep on it every single night
a great night of sleep allows you to be
healthier be more arrested and have more
energy throughout the day and on the
brand new 8 sleep pod 3 you can sleep as
cold as 55 degrees fahrenheit or as hot
as 110 degrees fahrenheit that's the
secret of thermoregulation better sleep
better energy get yourself innate sleep
you can go to hsleep.com pomp today to
go ahead and get 150 off your order
aidsleep.com
not only do i sleep on it every night it
literally changed my life and i begged
the founders to let me invest in the
company
eightsleep.com go get yourself an eight
sleep pod and get a better night of
sleep
one thing you know you used to you could
go to and you'd they'd have a butcher
right
well those don't you know that that
doesn't exist and so a lot of grocery
stores won't even know where the beef
comes from they they can't tell you
because they actually they have that you
know that wholesale market that i talked
about earlier so you don't really know
the butchers don't know
and so i don't eat supermarket beef but
i know a lot of people have to so what
i'm going to do is i'm going to pay a
little extra for it because that's one
thing that you should you know if you're
going to use that retail market through
a supermarket you should basically look
for the grass fed look for the organic
because it's it's better than that crap
beef that they they're probably giving
you
and that crap beef like i said it could
be from africa it could be from brazil
it can breed from texas but you're not
going to know and the people that are
basically selling you they're not going
to know either
and so if you can eliminate some of
those deceptions
then just drill down as close as you can
and you sh you're going to be okay
as you're doing that you have to be very
intentional about creating a new market
access on how to get your pure animal
protein that's where you start pure
animal protein in pure produce and
that's what the beef initiative is
accomplishing all right before we get to
uh eliminating the grocery store from uh
from kind of the supply chain um when
when you go and you buy uh if you have
to you're traveling or something right
uh when you cook it on a grill
do you put anything on it it's like what
is the treatment from you you purchased
it until it goes in your mouth right
what are you doing to the extraction i
forgot to bring up that i i do make my
own butter but whenever i'm at the
grocery store i'll get the best
grass-fed butter that i can find
so you look at butter you're like really
well i don't cook with oil i cook with
tallow and i use butter so i'll cook
whenever i'm traveling across the united
states in my pickup truck which i will
go to that a little bit later i carry a
cast iron skillet with me and i'll use
it wherever i can and i just put salt
and pepper and freaking butter on a
steak and i cook it and i eat it and
it's better than any freaking steakhouse
that you can find yeah and if any if
you're the consumer man just flames you
know whatever you have of course
and
for your diet specifically uh are you
one of these folks who just eats meat
like the true kind of hardcore carnivore
diet i'm not a hundred percent incarnate
or not okay are you eating ice cream and
snickers bars sometimes i'll freaking
grab a snack oh yeah all right so what
does your diet look like in uh kind of
on an average day are you eating other
vegetables and fruits or like what does
that look like i used to quite often if
i eat anything in abundance beyond you
know purity i'll eat bacon and eggs all
the time you know i was on the plane
yesterday and i made a homemade
breakfast taco i brought that thing out
and everybody started sniffing and
looking around on the airplane i was
cracking up so you know those are those
moments that are fun but you know i eat
a lot of fruit you know i'll definitely
eat some fruit i love you know avocados
and stuff like that i just keep it
simple and once you start really making
your diet more simple like that you you
understand that you don't need all these
other
like
different types of varieties of
nutritional delivery to your system if
you break down beef and especially
grass-fed grass finished or even or
organic grain finished beef because we
do both in the beef initiative you're
going to find out
there's nothing that matches up as far
as the vitamins the minerals and the
true nutritional delivery to your system
there's nothing else in the world that
we can have access to now
on on a larger scale that is better for
you than pure animal protein so what you
do is once you understand that you you
really do eliminate a lot of the options
that are nefarious at certain times or
they're just not needed you're just
making profit for somebody because
you're the recycling bin yeah the
recycling bin is such a good way to
describe it because uh no one wants to
be the recycling bin right i would i
would actually argue that you should use
trash bin because that elicits even more
emotional people get kind of butt hurt
so of course i have to ease into it
so
you mentioned earlier about going closer
to the source right and we mentioned in
the beginning that you've got the
rancher uh who's then got the processor
who's got the supplier who's got the
grocery store uh you actually try to cut
out quite a bit of that supply chain so
describe a little bit when you're at
home
what do you do to get kind of the
healthiest uh beef that you feel the
most confident in terms of i know where
this is coming from sure
what i did in the very beginning you
know i wrote the i got into food
intelligence i told you i've been doing
this for about three years and so after
you know i got off i'd embedded myself
in a harvest company last year so i
needed to go across the midwest i
started in texas all the way to the
border of canada all the way back to
texas and going and researching grain
companies doing the harvest and seeing
where we were right when i got back to
texas i said i know what i need to do
here we go so i went up and shook a
rancher's hand
and in my local community in which i
kind of stay where i grew up
one of my home bases now went up and
shook his hand and basically i said
let's have a tell me why you do what you
do
teach me i want to know what you're
doing he was the same place he came from
the same soil and so we developed a
relationship by saying that you know
that's whenever the beef initiative
kicked off so
and whenever i'm in that part it is
canyon texas it's in the texas panhandle
well his name is justin trammell he owns
panhandle meats
and what panhandle meats is is he's his
own
uh producer he's an animal producer of
foul hog and beef okay okay so now
within this year 2022 he opened up his
own microprocessing center so he is
feeding the community so anytime i need
anything i say hey justin i need a side
of beef i need a half a cow i need a
quarter of a cow okay well also i need
some hog i need some bacon i need some
sausage you got any chickens so the
first touch point that i do as far as
basically acquiring my food is i talk to
that rancher and then everything else
spawns off from there i've heard you say
shake a rancher's hand a couple of times
uh over the last couple of months what
exactly does that mean in terms of the
importance of it sure what are you
trying to get out of that interaction
well in
that was the story of justin trammell
let me go into segway into cole walton
of knc cattle down there south of austin
okay he's the number one supplier of our
beef right now what i did is i i did a
lot of phone calls not a lot probably
two or three and you know everybody's
pretty much suspect to me in the
beginning because there's so much
corruption and manipulation these
ranchers want to be left alone they want
to steward the land and they want to
stir the animals well once i went up
there and
cole invited me out to his ranch
and what i did because he's from texas
he's a texas cowboy i'm a texas cowboy
he's generational i'm generational and
there's something there to be said about
having that respect and that level of
understanding of how you approach
another person and how we were raised is
you better go up and look somebody in
the eye and you better shake their damn
hand and you better establish a
communication system that you two
understand
and if you can do that now as an
individual in this nation in this world
right now it's a power move back into a
new form of communication that we've
lost
so the validity and the importance and
the value of asia you know because i
always thought whenever i was in big
tech i got decided to do a study it was
the study of the division of
interpersonal communication and what
technology was going to do to that
interpersonal communication and i did a
lot of research on certain universities
and what were they predicting with
texting emailing and now look where we
are so the division of interpersonal
communication is is a pandemic in that
epidemic within itself within the united
states and the world because it's
leveraged against us now our digital
world is is is not
sometimes it has a lot of deception in
it right 100 right and so if we can have
that understanding that basically
relationship building is the most
important thing that you can do in your
life right now it starts with that
handshake and with cole bolton it
started with the handshake and it taught
you two guys from texas that have
respect for each other and where we come
from where our ancestors come from and
if if people will look at that and look
at the true value of that where is the
store value of that well it's a lifelong
relationship now that we're using to
leverage to feed people basically give
them market access to a new lifestyle
and a new consumption model that is
based on health and when you mention
market access obviously the grocery
store controls the market access because
whatever they go when they uh um are
able to get from their suppliers they're
putting in the store and that's the only
access you have is to whatever they're
selling if you're kind of the average
person
by going directly to the rancher
themselves uh and cutting out the
grocery store maybe even the suppliers
or whoever uh you're drastically
increasing your market access to what
you want because you're able to talk
directly to them yeah talk a little bit
more about what you and cole are doing
in terms of trying to bring uh one
education but also two uh you know
healthier beef to uh to millions people
sure
and to kind of give credit to where
credit is due right here we have justin
we have a lot of ranchers now that come
through the beef initiative but there
was three major ranchers that stepped up
and saw that what i was trying to do
wanted to get on board one of those was
jason rick of rick ranches and we just
had a conference out in colorado at his
ranch what he talked about and it was it
was the same day i talked to all three
of those guys and every one of them said
a vertical integration
what do you mean by that and you heard
me earlier say vertical integration back
into human health is the vertical
integration back into a decentralized
food system what does that mean well it
starts with the soil that's the source
you start with the soil and then the
grass then the cow then the producer
rancher animal producer then the
processor okay well cole and i and jason
and justin every one of us have a
decentralized market access
through that processing center once that
animal is produced processed
and ready to be delivered to you and me
well we don't have to have permission
now we are the ones that are saying we
get to sell that beef to you and we get
to sell it to you and you and you it's
like a direct to consumer product
in the technology world you're basically
going direct to consumer with healthy
beef yeah and a lot of people have tried
it and they haven't had much luck
well i think it's too centralized and
you know we're in bitcoin the reason one
of the most
strongest
and i think overlooked
aspects of bitcoin is the decentralized
mindset okay i come from networking
computer networking until i got started
in technology
decentralization right now is the most
important power move that you can have
and so whenever you can actually get the
best
nutrition that is out there in the world
right now in a decentralized way
that is actually the lifestyle that is
the power move that you're looking for
and so whenever you create a vertical
integration that is decentralized
where you don't have to ask for
permission anymore then basically you're
going to have success if you have a
centralized
type of system that's not a vertical
integration it's a linear in integration
then you're going to have too many
people making decisions and you're going
to have to ask permission from each one
of those is that permission from you
know as far as you know farm to table
like we said you know is that going to
be controlled by a chemical company is
it going to be controlled by a
processing company is it going to be
called controlled by a distribution
company is it going to be controlled by
a supermarket is it going to be trolled
by a health department is going to be
controlled every one of those you have
to battle through and say well that's
not very easy so that's why it hasn't
been successful because they haven't
been able to decentralize the market
access that vertical integration
what goes into building one of these
microprocessors
i've been working for two years now and
looking deep into it
in the state of texas we have over 200
processing centers as i said micro
processing centers
not the big giant processing centers the
smaller ones
and what they're they're not complex
really what they are is a lot of it's
freezer space you have a harvest shoot
then you have processing shoot then you
basically package the animal and then of
course you freeze one thing that you
i didn't say right there is aging the
beef
so you have sections
okay in a processing center and just to
be super granular uh and i apologize to
anyone who doesn't want the uh uh kind
of the the ground truth if you will
right uh animal shows up it's alive
right uh the animal is held there for
some period of time could be a short
period or a long period
the animal is slaughtered the animal is
then cut up
the animal is then potentially aged it's
aged first before it's cut out okay so
uh if the animal is slaughtered and
going to be aged it will then just sit
there it then is cut up and then
packaged and frozen right and then waits
to be delivered to whether it is the
supplier or in this case direct to the
case 80 right now it's wholesale so it's
we don't have any control over that but
yeah you sum it up you basically in in
within our model of decentralized market
access and the vertical integration
let's talk about feedlot you know
feedlot factory farming is what it's
called well those
thousands of cattle are stacked usually
on top of each other we'll see that's
the process uh and again this is me
being super dope no no we need to be uh
alive or dead alive alive okay so
they're stacked on top of each other
when they're alive yeah they become they
call fat cows okay so you take them to a
fat cow you know weight because that you
know that's where the money is the fat
counts
but see the the producer and the rancher
is not making that money it's the
processing centers and so right there
but if you go through something like
ours you say well the cow shows up and
then hangs out there a long time or no
in a regenerative decentralized way and
what's what we're doing within the beef
initiative and each one of these
ranchers and many more
and that people don't realize is that
cow has the best life that you could
hope for it is stewarded from a calf all
the way to that day that is going to
basically be harvested well it shows up
it might be there a day or two but it
doesn't know anything because they
change pastures all the time because
they're doing rotational grazing so that
cow shows up to be harvested it's not a
big thing it's not stress because you
don't want to stress out a cow
because you you get these cows that are
supermarket beef a lot of times they're
extremely stressed and whenever you have
that adrenaline rush at the time that
they're harvested it tastes the beef and
that's another thing
this blows my mind right which is uh we
know in humans if uh we had a child
psychological uh development uh like a
psychologist right on recently and uh
she talked about look if the mother is
super stressed out during pregnancy yeah
there are physiological changes that
occur in the child um if uh a child's
mother during pregnancy is addicted to
meth yeah there's physiological changes
to the child uh and so when we know that
in humans
this idea uh i think sometimes gets
almost like mocked like what do you mean
if the cow is stressed out yeah
why would it not change sure the
physiological structure of the cow if it
is stressed if it has high adrenaline if
it has whatever and then you're going to
take that animal and put in your body
and so i don't see any labels of like
chill cow stressed cow at the grocery
store
right and so when you talk about this is
this an intentional thing or is it just
something that we've noticed where in
certain processing centers the cows are
super stressed out and other ones
they're not yeah i think it's been a
cause and effect type thing right you
know as we as we grew in size and
capacity to be able to you know to raise
millions and millions of millions of
cattle on the commodity side of things
as far as commodity grains well you got
to have a you know a match system it's
like okay we're bringing you know
there's processing centers that will
harvest 3 000 cattle in a day
okay you look at that type of capacity
well they're just on an assembly line
and that's what everybody hates that's
what the vegans hate that's the
vegetarians age it's you know the
globalist pointed out it's like oh this
is horrible and it is it's destructive
it's not all like that there's a lot of
different you know once again we can't
generalize
but
to basically if you have the awareness
that that type of stuff is true and
valid it's something that is is known to
happen as far as on the on the bad side
of that stressing and affecting the
psychological um
well-being of that animal does matter a
hundred percent just like it does in
humans and so if you look at that and
you take ownership that that is true and
factual then you can look at the type of
animal producers that that's what they
live for they want that animal to have
the best life that it can and then they
want to honor that animal to turn it
into a new form of energy okay the
commodity cowboy route it's not that the
commodity cowboys are making that a bad
stressful thing for the uh for the cow
it's not them
it's the processors it's the global guys
that are basically if that meat is
tainted with adrenaline it's
psychological damage at time of
harvesting it's not the producers it's
the global
processors and so when we think about uh
kind of these microprocessors how much
money did it cost to build one of these
things
well
it's i'm glad you bring that up because
i've been holding it back as far as
what what's another i always work in
solutions
and so we're announcing probably within
two weeks that we're going to have the
beef initiative association council what
that is is we've looked at the
microprocessors in the state of texas
and we want to have a and this is this
is ambitious but we want to have a
microprocessor
in every county in the state of texas
just like my grandfather did and just
like justin's grandfather did just like
cole's grandfather did justin's opened
up his he does about 30 cattle a week
he feeds the community how many people
could 30 cattle feed you know in a week
you know it's not that much that that
goes to show you that there's not
competition here but he feeds everybody
he is making a dang good living now he
has a pillar of strength on a monetary
system than he never had
so he is full of capacity at all times
he is producing and feeding everybody
that he wants okay well there's going to
be another justin pop-up well let's look
at cole he's now opening up his
processing center south of austin he's
going to be about 250 cattle a week so
his reach is a little bit more and he's
going to go a little bit more regional
from his community that's his number one
goal but now within the beef initiative
we're actually right now because we're
stepping up our volume is increasing
tenfold we can ship beef right now
across 48 states and we've been doing
that now since january we just haven't
advertised it because we wanted to make
sure we had a base layer foundational
level so going back to the question
justin back in the day whenever he did
it under a million dollars coal's going
to be you know the size of how much
you're going to process these days and
times
it's it's you know
it's hard to say because of inflation
but it's not that hard to accomplish on
the big scale of things a
microprocessing center the the amount of
cost and the amount of return that you
get as far as community building
a pillar of strength and monetary
it's a damn good move and so what we're
going to do we're going to go we have
usda precedence now within beef
initiative is in processing centers you
can come to us we will advise you from
the ground up all the way to your last
inspection within the state in which
we're going to do texas first to where
you're pretty sure you have a rubber
stamp that you can make this happen
we look at your capital expenditures we
look what you have as far as investments
we look at your geography what you're
going to do we look at the type of
market access that you're going to
create in your community we get all that
built in and then that way whenever we
consult you you're gonna know that
you're pretty much in the right
direction and that you can actually you
know start really changing the changing
the game here because it does start with
the processing centers so if we go to
the four large ones uh i started
googling around and frankly my mind was
blown yeah um and uh the reason i
started google was because uh in one of
your pieces you wrote two things that
caught my attention the first was most
of them are owned by families i would
have known them for long periods of time
and the second was you made a comment
that
i think was cargill has so much
technology and intelligence that it
rivals the cia
let's start with the families first
which is uh good or bad that the same
families have controlled these and been
able to consolidate so much of it and is
it
if it's bad is it that the families are
bad or is it that it's just been
consolidated well i'll tell you what i
mean
we'll look at cargill and it's not the
smartest thing to do to talk crap on
cargill so i don't i just kind of point
out what it is i mean it's it's
definitely families that have been close
to the money since the very beginning of
us really you know being around money
they go way back they have a history and
what they do now is they have the
capacity to be able to control
basically shipping lanes they have you
know they have their barges they have
everything from the very beginning of
that seed to the very end of that seed
they control and they control it on a
global front well to have that much
control over the the seed itself
is basically it takes an intelligence
apparatus they do have uh basically
seven 000 people that work for them and
they mirror the cia as far as
intelligence you know they do have
satellites they do basically look at
things they innovate with technology and
way that big money can being that close
to money that they can do is very
centralized it's very hush-hush
and you know a lot of it's very good a
lot of it's you know they basically but
for that one family to control the
access to the seeds of humanity that's a
little ridiculous and if you put it in
perspective there's no way in hell that
should happen but they always come up
with reasons why
they are the stewards of the seed of the
world
no it shouldn't be that way you look at
all the seeds like we had for in america
a lot of our heirloom seeds now are
under lock and key
and we don't have access to those seeds
anymore what we have access is to
genetically modified seeds which are
controlled by these families what is
fascinating to me is that uh
he who owns the seed right or the supply
of the seed has so much power seems like
that's kind of crazy this has been going
on for centuries yeah if you go back to
ancient rome i think it's uh commodus
was the emperor of rome at the time
marcus aurelius's son and uh if i
remember the story correctly uh one of
his advisors or or kind of his uh close
friends he essentially said hey you're
going to be in charge for a while and
i'm just going to go and you know screw
off essentially
uh and let me know if anything goes
wrong
and one of the things that that advisor
did was he actually manipulated the
supply of grain
to the city of rome and his
goal or his plan was to essentially
create near famine
and then to step in and essentially
re-release the grain supply back to the
people and be the hero of course
now
for those that know nothing about
ancient rome a lot of the grain came
from egypt and would would uh come over
and so he was essentially diverting once
it got to what is now known as italy uh
into his own personal warehouses and
kind of all this stuff right
that was crazy to look back and say what
do you mean one guy could basically
divert the entire grain supply of a city
bring them to near famine and obviously
what happened is he screwed it up
because he was an idiot uh and literally
people were starving in the streets and
there was uprising and social unrest and
and all these different things uh and
finally the emperor woke up and was like
hey maybe i should uh you know step in
here and do my job
that is
a.d
right here we are in 2022 talking about
the same damn thing of like who controls
the supply of grain
which is crazy to me it is and you look
at i mean i'm glad you point that out i
mean i did a piece and i called it let
the poor court the rich and i took uh
sections of you know city of god out of
it
and i quoted and a lot of people didn't
know that i was quoting from the city of
god because it reads as of today
and you go whoa what that was 2 000
years ago
you know you look at the city of god and
what it was you know it was a control of
food consumption back then as far as
people know about rome you know a lot of
a lot of their agricultural was because
of their you know their soldiers their
warriors and they would go off and so
throughout time their food supply
basically got diminished and their
nutritional value as a society depleted
and that was always like you just
pointed out by their rulers
and so you look at who are our rulers
now well it's the basically the people
that control the access the source of
the seed itself
is the ones that we actually are
answering to and we don't we're
answering to them in ways that we have
no clue about
and they're able to you know really
control the narrative the the the
delivery of content you know the
consumption model of your audio your
video and the food itself and that's
what we have to go and you know it we
can't be surface level understanding of
what food is anymore
and understanding history just as you
pointed out very well and understanding
how we can circumvent around that type
of control it's like we don't have to
really dissect it forever what we have
to do is to just be aware of it and say
no i'm not going to play that game
anymore i don't have to
and that's you know what we're doing
within the beef initiative we're just
circumventing around it so
your approach is to essentially say i
cannot change the
gmo kind of esg argument now and so
let's route around it sure there are
other countries um specifically in
europe uh it seems like it's probably
where this has taken uh uh kind of hold
the most
where as a country whether it's from the
leadership or it is from the population
they have just rejected uh this gmo
kind of entire movement to some degree
all the way to the point where uh i know
france has a gmo uh
band yeah uh talk a little bit about
what is going on in europe with kind of
these genetically modified uh um kind of
bands to some degree well we'll start
with the american public we've always
been the guinea pig for this big global
you know
industrial food industry right and so
when gmos first came out you know europe
totally collectively they said screw you
guys man we're not consuming this crap
you know i've been around the world
you've been around the world you know
we've seen different places and the type
of foods that you can eat you know
especially packaged and processed food
well europe's always been very good
about pushing back you know france has
always kind of led that as well the
netherlands you know they they do as
much as they can a lot of people don't
realize the netherlands creates
second and largest amount of produce in
the world so they do you know export a
lot of food out of there well they've
stayed closer to the seed of nutrition
than we have and they've done these
pushbacks against the genetically
modified food
you get it in europe as a whole they've
done that and they've been very
successful up to now
and now people that i talk to friends i
have in the uk friends i have in spain
friends i have in portugal friends i
have in ireland friends i have in france
friends i have in you know the
netherlands they're all saying the same
thing now the pushback is not there
anymore and they're flooding with highly
processed food and europe is seeing
something basically that they haven't
seen they're coming in on our coattails
as far as this metabolical bankruptcy
that we're going through and so the
pushback has always been there by europe
and they've done a very good job but
what we need for us in america and for
the europeans to do especially the
french because they've led that let's
get back to where we were in this let's
understand what they're planning for us
with the land grabs that they're doing
in the netherlands you know and the
different types of distributions that
they're going to establish with this new
fake commodity system that they're
introducing is it possible to roll back
uh kind of how much progress the
chemical companies
have made hundred percent okay how do we
do that well one thing
and this is where we have to become
strong individuals strong minded and
strong with our desires you know i
always ask people
why do you desire what you desire you
know get get in front of that
accountability mirror and take a look
you will all have to do it in certain
aspects of our life you should be doing
it we need to do it with our consumption
okay our consumption is basically called
a consumer demand
let's let's change our consumer demand
as an individual and once we do that we
we are in control we just don't give
ourselves credit for that
if we create a whole new lifestyle call
the beef initiative it's international
lifestyle that people just don't
understand yet and and people are
starting to understand what i'm talking
about
is like hey i have the right i don't
have to ask for permission to eat what i
want to eat but i'm not going to eat
something that i'm not educated about
so i'm going to go out there and
establish relationships with communities
wherever you stand is what you have to
look at somebody in washington state is
going to be somebody different in
philadelphia and what we have to do is
get each individual start realizing
change of consumer demand and quit
looking at food as entertainment
it actually needs to be very intentional
my grandfather grew his land consumed
his food and consumed those animals and
that produce on a survival mindset okay
that gave a lot of strength because they
knew first and foremost if i'm not
really intentional about how this seed
goes from
the ground and into my body
then i'm going to deplete my power as an
individual and if people can kind of
look at that it doesn't have to be
extreme but if you can point your
consumer demand in a different place
they start paying attention how
important is education in terms of
obviously
there's a lot that you said today yeah i
wasn't taught that in school right uh
you know unfortunately uh most parents
they don't know this information they
weren't taught it in school uh
where do you see the sources of
education today and how important would
it be if we could even get some of this
education into schools or other forms
for for young people to consume well and
that's a fantastic question in canyon
texas you know i live right close to an
agricultural university that's where i
grew up i mean there's a museum there
that i'm going to have a regional food
summit based on education
so you look at these institutions and a
lot of them still you know they steward
a lot of great you know information
some intelligence though and some
information and education is backed by
these chemical companies in these grain
companies
understanding that say okay well i want
to go learn you of course at the
university level but the one thing that
i found out with every rancher that i
deal with they don't sell their product
what they do is they educate
and so you go up there and you create
that relationship with that rancher you
want to talk about education that starts
from the seed up you're going to find
out everything you want to know and as
the beef initiative does grow
we're introducing new channels that you
can go out there and get educated like i
let people write for my sub stack and
they they basically i say what are you
trying to accomplish what is your why
here and a lot of them are young guys
right now that are they're bringing a
lot of freaking food intelligence that i
i don't have time to provide
so i think collectively you know
especially within the bitcoin space and
within the ranching space there's a lot
of education moving forward
what i did within the beef initiative
and i'm just now really kind of
launching it out there is we have a
scholarship program
in colorado what we did is uh jason rick
of rick ranches he's the one that you
know i referred to earlier he basically
gets a scholarship in his name now it's
backed by one full bitcoin and what he
gets to do in us collectively as a beef
initiative we could start bringing in
people that want to be educated in a
different way
we want observational science of biology
and how land and how the uh the the
animal is stewarded in that way that's a
new form of education that we're going
to start introducing and if we can kind
of organize that in a way that is open
sourced that is crowdfunded and
crowdsourced then the education model
kind of changes that awareness changes
when we think about um
educating the individual as the consumer
right if we move upstream i guess a
little bit to the grocery stores
themselves is there any hope in uh local
grocery stores maybe are more receptive
than the national grocery stores in
terms of hey you know you all are
responsible for the food that you are
selling to the consumer uh if we can
change the consumer demand what if we
can change the grocery store right yeah
is there anything going on there there
is and actually if you look at the the
there's i talked to cole yesterday and i
said hey you know what what should i
bring up that's current affairs state of
affairs right now because that's what
the beef initiative is we're the voice
of the rancher that's on the ground and
he said there is some legislation that's
moving forward to where it will help us
regional processors the smaller price
processors have better direct access and
market access
to these supermarkets into where we can
create
a wholesale type of uh you know
[Music]
access to the retail side of things so
the rancher uh can basically say hey i'm
gonna set up a microprocessor and then
rather than take my micro the product
from the microprocessor i have to sell
it to the supplier who then go sells it
to the grocery store yeah similar uh uh
to tesla that says hey we're going to
sell cars but we're not going to put
them in car dealerships
and our own car dealerships directly to
the consumer uh now all of a sudden the
rancher with a microprocessor can go
great
to the grocery store
which sounds like that's a win for the
end consumer it really does but it also
sounds like maybe there's a little bit
of pain there for the suppliers who may
not like that
well you know it's capitalism right and
what is capitalism truly driven by
consumer demand
and so looking at that let's reflect on
our summit in georgia that's coming up
in september
that's about will harris of white oak
pastures what he did he was the first
regenerative farmer and rancher to sell
grass-fed beef to whole foods okay he
created his basically retail hostess
wholesale system based on that so
whole foods brought him in before bezos
of course bought him out and everything
but he created consumer demand for his
product by doing exactly what we're
talking about i think that we have the
power now and we have maybe some
legislation that's going to allow us to
do that in a way that we haven't had in
the past
explain more what he did so he went to
whole foods and said hey i'm not a
supplier but i want to sell my product
in your stores uh here's a bunch of
people who want it or how did that work
yeah pretty much what he did he brought
a lot of studies to two whole foods
whole foods i mean they're supposed to
be the you know yeah that's a good
person to go put some pressure on right
and so what he did is like hey this is
how we can be a true you know nature
lover if you're gonna love the earth
then let's let's look what i do with the
earth what i do with the soil well i use
these land tools
and they're called cows and what i do is
i basically i save my ranch by using
these land tools this livestock when you
want to be part of that here's the
studies here's how we can regrow soil
without using chemicals without using
fertilizers without using pesticides and
so he made a case for being the best
beef that whole foods should bring on
and so by him doing that he did it not
an exploitative way but a very
a good way they got attention and so
therefore all of a sudden whole foods is
hell yeah people love this grass-fed
beef
let's turn it into a retail you know
option for our consumers and then
collectively
his current consumers helped drive that
consumer demand and whole foods
understood that that was the best
business move that they could and right
now you have everybody across the nation
they buy white oak pasture beef from
whole foods because that's the market
access or they buy it from mark white
oak pastures itself so will harris has a
wholesale and he has retail and he did
it all on his own and that's one of the
reasons we're having that summit there
just beyond him being will harris but
people get to see that it is possible
that it we have a case study we have
proof of work and that's what beef
initiative is doing right now
collectively with jason rick justin cole
all the other producers that are coming
in we are creating that same type of
model and mindset i feel like ranchers
uh when the meat of the ranchers there's
kind of a mutual respect as you've
referenced a few times um it's just a
game where if enough ranchers get
together uh the processors the suppliers
they are uh actually serving at the
whims of the rancher uh an individual
rancher is too weak yeah uh by
themselves and don't doesn't have enough
leverage but
i don't know 20 50 of ranchers in the
country get together and say enough's
enough well
power shifts yeah i'm sorry to interrupt
because i get excited when i get to ask
this and i the cowboy in me kind of
comes out you damn right we can and what
we can do is we can have these damn
commodity cowboys and i say this with
respect is to grow some balls and let's
get out there and let's quit freaking
funneling our nutrition to the
processors let's say you're going to
listen to us
and we're going to change things because
we're being shorted out here a lot of
guys they're leveraged hard and they
can't do that but as we grow with
awareness and education like we're doing
today on the show what we're doing is
we're giving confidence to the ranchers
to say we do have more control than we
thought we did
we do see proof of work now we do want
to change our protocol where we can
eliminate some of these these captured
pros prospects or processes in which we
have to operate into
it's a slow game it's low it took us a
long time to get here it's not just all
of a sudden you know 50 years to create
an issue well it's not 50 years to solve
it i say the beef initiative right now
in this phase is a 10-year program but
within this decade what we can do is we
can actually bring
the rancher back home and we can bring
basically our local cattle back home so
when you see this problem i think we can
outline kind of theoretically here's the
solutions one of the things we haven't
talked about is there's immense friction
in this process
obviously it
would be pressured from the processors
from the suppliers maybe even the
grocery stores
there's an element of having to convince
the american consumer to change their
demand patterns uh not impossible but
still education all of that um but
there's examples outside of the cattle
industry that we can point to uh
somebody like an amos miller who's
recently been in the news um that
there's other pressures from regulatory
bodies from the government uh describe a
little bit for folks the amos miller
kind of story and kind of your
understanding of uh what that is because
i think there's well differences there
are some similarities between the
individuals saying hey i want to do
something different and you know he's
been doing that it seems like for quite
a while
well he he kind of he he's
he he sets the standard on
being able to stand up you know and he
stands up to the federal you know
governments what he does
you know and he's a rancher and he has
access to a lot of different lands
and so you know he's out i believe he's
nevada correct and so what he's done is
he's taken a stance
and he he's willing to pioneer into the
understanding and the awareness of what
type of overreach and what type of
regulatory capture has happened in
america and a lot of his story has been
basically you know there's a lot of
prohibition against that type of
information
and so whenever you as a rancher and a
producer in the united states of america
that's why you don't really know that's
why the general public doesn't
understand what's really going on
because it's risky business and you know
with amos miller and what he's gone
through on the federal level you know
it's a movie within itself it's a book
within itself and there's a lot of
aspects of the story you know and you
brought it up yesterday bring up one
little touch point to what you read and
what made you curious about amos miller
yeah well there was two main points i
think the first one was uh recently in
the news i saw a headline and it's uh
you know positioned as like independent
farmer or however they described it uh
is now being uh fined by the federal
government and okay i'm sure that
there's fines you know every single day
they get levied and uh most of them are
because somebody broke rules now we can
argue over the validity of the rules
right but somebody uh either
intentionally or unintentionally broke
rules and it's fine all right that
happens every single day in the united
states of america uh
but then i read the second line which
was uh he's was selling
to his local community he's got kind of
a subscription service going and all
this and uh by no means am i an expert
but what caught my attention was that he
essentially was trying to sell uh raw
milk and other things that uh obviously
a portion of the population believes is
healthier
and they want access going back to kind
of there's market demand for these
things and so capitalistic society
somebody will step in and serve that
demand uh and he's happening happens to
do that
and i moved on and i thought to myself
okay you know there's a fine it'll get
figured out and uh frankly i'm not a a
food connoisseur nor a food expert right
so i'll move on in the day and yesterday
i saw uh somebody who'd recently been on
the show dave collum he tweeted an
article uh and it was about a federal
raid on a farm uh this is going back
almost a decade yeah and so i sort of
say wait a second like this is not a
one-time thing that's been going on
recently this is a
multi-year
battle essentially yes uh and there's
arguments on both sides that some people
agree with one side some people agree
with others but majority of people just
say i don't know yeah right they say
well yeah it sounds good to have you
know the fda look at the food and make
sure that like i don't eat it and die
on the other side you have people saying
but if i can actually make it healthier
and sell it directly to people who want
it and you're have two consenting adults
entering into a contract uh
then we should be able to do that as
well
so it's a fascinating
issue because uh the deeper you go the
more complexity there is
and frankly you can see where education
ultimately ends up being the single most
important thing throughout that entire
situation it's the best leverage you can
have and yes that's what we're doing
here and what you know with miller it is
you look at the dairy industry and you
know everybody thinks ooh pasteurized
skin milk is that it's the most
unhealthy thing in my opinion that you
could be consuming it takes all the
animal fat it takes all the vitamins and
minerals out of your milk they boil milk
and say oh it's safe you're not going to
die from drinking raw milk so you look
at miller what and this is something
that people are starting to be educated
basically on and they do they want
market access and they want to include
it into their consumption model is raw
milk well that's how we got here that's
how my mother was raised that's how i
was i used to wake up as a child on the
front porch there was milk
and it was every other day you had milk
delivered to you it wasn't boiled and
wasn't boiled it was straight from the
cow guess what man this big little
all of this that you just said is
regulatory capture and ignorance i'm not
saying it's bad ignorance it's just
ignorance that we have been kept away
from
understanding what true nutrition is
what pure nutrition is and what pure
animal protein and pure animal fat
it's how we got here people and they say
well
we're so populated now that you know we
can't do that it's just impossible no
it's not that's their narrative that's
their argument and so what he's doing
he's fighting the system and he's saying
i have a group of people
that want my product i am actually
providing
more benefit to the soil to the earth
into my community than any global
corporation that has captured the dairy
market
and so
you you know you poke the bear guess
what happens you have to go up and you
have to fight you get fined let's talk
about fines okay let's talk about how
fines work well
let's go back to jbs okay they're the
biggest meat processor in the united
states they're out of brazil they
actually
you know they have been fined hundreds
of millions of dollars just this last
year they were settled out of court
federal court 56 million so i had to pay
56 million dollars why
the the what it was is during covid that
they made basically over
500 million dollars on price
manipulation of beef in the united
states got it okay the general consumer
doesn't know that so by the way 500
million uh of revenue okay 500 million
of profit in a 56 million fine yes that
sounds like a pretty good margin
[Music]
consulting company to do it again for us
let's let's make sure that you know we
have that lined up on our next move here
chess you know let's let's play some
chess with the federal government and
they do it very well
and you know the the owner of and the
founder of jbs served two years in
prison in brazil for bribing uh the
brazilian president
along with politicians and they had a
fast track of bribing politicians in the
united states guess what settle out of
court jbs has been
fined hundreds of millions of dollars in
the general public doesn't know about it
the department of justice should be all
over jbs well why isn't it well we live
in the united states we have regulatory
capture we have lobbyists we have big
money we have global
plans
and it's part of a global industrial
food shift and if you don't understand
the source of the seed of the corruption
how can you understand the source of the
seed of the solution
so if you're going to have this
globalist movement that is okay and can
afford these fines okay what are we
going to do we're going to get this guy
named amos miller and we're going to
make an example of him and we're going
to put him all over the media and we're
going to let everybody know that oh my
gosh what he's doing is bad for your
health it's bad for your children's
health you know we can prove it
pasteurization and basically this new
type of food that we're introducing to
the food system is what you really need
to be paying attention to don't pay
attention to all the corruption that
happens over here on the side and who is
basically let's let's look at the
politicians let's look at the federal
government that's going after miller who
are they who are funding them that's the
type of food intelligence you need to
start introducing into your life
because
up to now it's been random we can't be
random with it
and when we think about these new things
that are introduced into the food supply
um obviously pasteurized milk and things
like that uh i think people put into a
bucket and they say uh it's milk yeah
right and they don't know the difference
between pasteurized versus
raw milk or whatever um and
milk is milk and milk's always been a
staple in the uh
diet and so they go to the store and
they buy it and they consume it
where i do think that people uh there's
there's debate maybe it's a a
politically correct way to say it right
is uh when you get into the
bioengineered
meats so this is uh uh impossible uh
food and all of these um
beyond me there's a couple other ones uh
they now have cracked from hey we'll
sell you the patties in the grocery
store to
oh you know burger king or mcdonald's or
wherever they've started to get into
that market yeah and you can go and you
can buy these and usually they'll tell
you hey you're buying a uh a patty that
is not meat it's the you know beyond
burger or whatever they want to call it
morning star farms they were one of the
first ones yeah and and so it's um in
some ways uh if you're a hip if you're
cool if you care about the environment
right you go and you buy this if you're
a vegan right you go and you buy this
whatever uh
but it's not hard to see a world where
like uh rather than there being internet
companies now everyone's just a company
and they happen to use the internet and
rather than having the you know
genetically modified burger it just
becomes the burger
and so
what is your thoughts about this whole
world of like fake meat that seems to be
the you know the sludge is taking over
is kind of like the critics argument
like what what's going on this episode
is brought to you by ledger the best
crypto hardware wallet everyone's heard
the phrase not your keys not your coins
and that's more true today than it's
ever been
ultimately a value proposition of
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies is
self-custody where you get to retain
ownership over your digital assets that
is what ledger specializes in they've
got multiple pieces of hardware and they
also have the ledger live mobile app
which makes it seamless to not only
retain control over your bitcoin but it
also allows you to interface with
exchanges lending platforms and other
types of software products if you're
interested in upping your self-custody
game go check out ledger today
shop.ledger.com again that's
shop.ledger.com go check them out and
start doing self custody you'll thank me
later well i know it's a slow roll into
change as far as them changing our food
consumption right
and you know the last year i think it
was basically last fall you know i
talked about kind of the fake meat
and i said there's going to be a global
marketing plan that gets released in
2022 and it's going to be based around
consumption of fake meat well sure
enough you know we go through and all of
a sudden everybody starts seeing fake
meat commercials they're seeing it
burger king they're seeing the schools
they're seeing everything and they
people are out there you know on social
media and they're saying i'm never
eating that damn 3d printed steak i'm
never eating that damn veggie burger
that you know looks like a hamburger
patty i'm not eating that sausage that
looks all flaccid and you know you have
all kinds of things that people are
talking about of fake meat that's the
distraction
what what i mean by that well
they pretty much know that you're not
going to go over there you know running
through the aisles can't wait to get to
your fake meat patties or your fake meat
steak what they are though and they've
already done it and a lot of
basically
um actions
and maneuvers are already moving forward
is they're going to inject
fake meat and let's say fake protein
let's go there i don't even want to use
the word meat anymore fake protein into
our food supply in ways that we don't
know you heard me talk about the fda and
the grass rule
the the labeling changes in which we do
you know how many people go and look at
their box and really can pronounce and
pronounce all those words right so it's
a play on the english language it's a
play on understanding words well now
what they're doing is you're seeing bugs
oh [ __ ] now we're gonna have to eat bugs
you know and they're teaching children
how to eat crickets as they teach them
how to brush their teeth i saw the video
where uh there's a guy
he's dressed up he must be important
he's got you know uh uh dressed the way
he's going to you know church on sunday
yeah and he's sitting in front of the
classroom uh and this you know young
kids exactly what you would expect in
kind of like an elementary classroom
looks like uh and he pulls out a bag
that you would see at the airport at the
grocery store at a convenience store or
whatever and it could have anything from
m ms to you know whatever other
processed stuff that they put in there
and he's basically telling the kids that
there's crickets yeah in this bag and
you know maybe they're chocolate-covered
crickets or maybe they're regular
crickets or whatever they've come up
with yeah and he's handed them out to
the kids and of course i see the video
because it only cracks into my world on
twitter if it's being mocked and
ridiculed and like this is insane uh
but it made me stop and say what the
[ __ ] is going on here yeah well it's
social engineering at its finest of
course you know because that's what we
do these days is we engineer society in
a way that they want us to be engineered
socially so you look at that and yeah
you know i've been like i said we've
traveled i've you know i used to go down
to oaxaca in mexico and chapellina's is
something that you can go and you can
get you know at the mark you walk up and
get a bag of chipolinas they can be you
know spicy or they can have you know
some type of you know caramel on and go
to asia same thing people have been
eating chipolinas crickets and
grasshoppers and locusts forever you
know it was it was something they does
have protein in it but what they don't
really you know explain with that type
of marketing and advertising is that
they already have stuff called cricket
dust cricket flower so what they've done
like with seed oils they've taken a weed
and basically made it one of the biggest
consumption commodities in the world
with that canola or any other type of
seed oil okay well they're going to do
the same thing with this fake protein be
pea protein soy protein crickets
whatever they come along with scorpions
whatever they want to do they'll
introduce interjected and injected into
our food supply and we won't even know
it because most of people out there are
okay with eating their pizza pockets and
their chicken attendees and they don't
even know what the hell it is and it's
not chicken well it's not pizza it's not
you know it's not pepperoni
because you look at i've worked with
some people
in the uh industrial food basically
factories the processing systems itself
used to you'd get a burrito and it was
it was a combination burrito and we're
just using this an example half of it
was beans half of it was beef okay great
well they can call it a beef and bean
burrito right and that's legal right
well now well [ __ ] beef is kind of more
expensive well let's put 70 beans and
let's put
30 beef well no let's let's do 30 beef
let's do 20
of soy protein and then we'll do 50
beans so throughout the time that
combination burrito has basically
started out exactly what it was said the
labeling laws have changed where now
that combination burrito can be 10 beans
it can be 80 soy and now
moving forward it will be 20
bucks
it'll be that type of
pea protein bug protein whatever they
say is actually healthier and it's
better for the planet they'll be putting
it into those products well the people
that are eating those products are
usually children and it's usually
mothers that are buying and fathers that
are buying that
label they're buying the wordage
saying heart healthy good for children
packed with protein 14 grams of protein
and they're they're saying you don't
need as much protein now so they're
manipulating society to think that you
do not need animal protein that
vegetable protein is ever even better
and basically by doing that they're able
to inject that fake protein into the
food supply it's absolutely insane yeah
this is uh and this is moving forward
hard one of the other things says we
talk about children uh blew my mind
uh the new york city mayor mayor adams
yeah uh he's very excited to tell people
that uh he doesn't eat meat uh he's uh
um i think he said he's vegetarian or
vegan or you know won't go i can tell uh
yeah well
he he uh he he he's made a lot of
promises and uh uh i was excited because
i thought that he understood bitcoin and
uh you know then all of a sudden started
talking about uh banning bitcoin mining
and i said i don't think you understand
right uh at all um and uh the part
that absolutely just sent me over the
edge was they're trying to remove meat
from the children's diet
in the schools so it's not even just
saying like it's one thing if you say
hey protein's important let's uh let's
not eat uh steak instead we're gonna eat
chicken or we're gonna eat you know uh
even crickets right frank franklin okay
but just this whole washing of like
protein essentially from the diets and
uh meatless mondays and coming up with
all these like crazy things yeah
it just falls back like just leave the
kids the [ __ ] alone yeah exactly right
and so what do you take as to
politicians stepping in and implementing
these kind of wide sweeping changes to
the diet inside of public schools it's
gonna be kind of a long answer but i'll
give it a reflection as i as a child
okay in the middle of texas
we used to you know at one point in time
they did feed us soy burgers back in the
70s well that soy was different then
okay it was probably a little bit
healthier you know it was probably good
you know to go ahead and use the school
system and basically provide kids that
weren't getting good protein that was a
supplement okay so be it it's a
subsidized supplement that had validity
and that was in the 1970s okay you look
at it now
and everything let's look at the health
of a freaking nation right now where our
kids are ages 5 to 11 now 46 of them are
obese or overweight that's crazy one out
of two is going to diabetes already has
diabetes that's the health of our kids
in this nation that is a [ __ ]
genocide
and if people do not start understanding
that
we're going to kill our kids in a way
that we don't see but we're going to let
these stupid politicians do it
that's where we say no more
and when we think about this um
it feels like the kids
they're helpless yeah they don't know
any better right they go to school and
whatever they're fed it's a it's a
belief that the teacher or the cafeteria
manager or the chef or whatever
they're just here to look out for me
like i live in a safe world right and
unfortunately there's kids who go to
school and that is the most dense and
supposed to be most nutritious meal that
they're gonna get all day yeah
and
that's where i think it just goes back
to like just leave the kids alone
exactly and actually
that should be the first thing that all
of us as adults responsible people
parents we're all parents we're going to
be parents probably a high percentage we
can look at ourselves and say okay but
what we have to do is we have to get
right it's like you know i talked to a
lot of doctors
and i said where do we start with the
education with our parents and dr mary
care she spoke at one of our conferences
she said that we have to treat it like
we're on an airplane okay that the
oxygen masks come down we've got to put
the auction max on ourselves first
and then once we understand what we're
up against what politicians like jackass
is doing in new york then we can look at
the solutions in which we can basically
get around of and so you look at this
the school programs i'll give you an
example coming from texas i love ranches
but you have a ranch out there and it's
the four sixes it used to be one of the
biggest ranches in the world
what they did they have a certain county
out there okay and i believe it's
guthrie county all right in guthrie
county texas with the four sixes it was
basically the whole county it's the
county square it's the town they took
over the skid the kids food programs it
was all from the ranch they gave the the
food program to the ranch
that ranch was able to get that school
system that independent school system
they improved attendance
health everything across the board
improved because that local community
fed their local independent school
district okay now let's look at what
they're doing in new york
and before he made those announcements i
believe it was at the beginning of the
year i think february or march
and we're talking about one of the bills
that you know the administration passed
and i said watch out they're going to
come after the food systems for the the
school systems that in new york is
exactly what they're doing they're
interjecting or they're injecting these
new fake commodity ideas
and then they'll inject it into the food
system of our children uh governor
abbott
has taken uh a bunch of uh migrants and
bust them to new york i'm surprised that
you guys aren't sending uh some meat up
there as well as a way to kind of try
they're going to drop off
like i said we're about to feed the
nation again
uh well when we speak about kids i think
one of the hot topics in
society in general today is uh china and
things like tick tock and kind of how
they're right
a large consumption
percentage uh from just like a
psychological perspective of children um
but china also has been buying up a lot
of farmland in the united states
what what do you read into
that is that just a country trying to
make money is there other things people
should be aware of or concerned about
well you look at china and you know
they're the most populous country in the
world they have a lot of people to feed
and their their consumption is different
but they you know their elites eat a lot
of our beef they do i mean that's that's
what they have to eat
and whenever i say there's an attack on
beef and everybody needs to understand
it's like you and i are the peasants
right modern-day peasants now you know
we're the ones that don't have that
market access peasants don't have market
access they're not getting rid of beef
they're just not going to give you
access to it so they're going to turn
beef into caviar for the average
consumer in the united states that's
their intentions and there's already 70
percent of the population across the
globe that are saying we're cutting back
on our meat because they don't even
include it within inflation okay we look
at china that's trying to feed their
nation right well they control a lot of
grain in the world on on the market on
the global market okay well they really
are dependent on the global food
industry so how do they circumvent
around that well you go to the bread
basket of the world which is basically
the great plains you know middle america
right and so what they've been doing
during kovid they bought over 200 000
acres of farmland that nobody was paying
attention to because everybody was
looking at gates what is the gates doing
well china kind of flew under the radar
and was able to acquire a lot of our
land and they're bringing a lot of
different type of technologies and
they're making a lot of plays
on how food is basically probably
consumed in their nation but also by own
on our farmland they get to control how
we consume and what we consume as well
so what they're doing is they're
basically creating a whole new silk road
of food distribution within the united
states itself
and when we see this
what are the things you're most worried
about is it things that they are doing
to american farmland uh to feed
themselves and so we want to be careful
as to what they're doing to the farmland
itself or is it uh things that they're
doing to the farmland which ultimately
leads to the food supply then that food
is then given to the american public
like where are you most concerned
right now what i'm concerned about in
the united states of america let's start
with the united states of america is
that
the lack of market access that we truly
have in the united states is far worse
than people understand i just drove 14
000 miles
across the south then that's kind of i'm
gonna go hit the
northwest i'm hitting idaho wyoming i'm
traveling around the world right now is
what i'm doing but get back to the point
i see tons of food deserts in the united
states that are feeding communities
there's a lot of times all you find in a
community is a convenience store and a
dollar general or a walmart within 70 to
100 miles that's our food distribution
in the united states right now and
people don't realize it because they're
not going out and seeing this country
anymore
so
when we look at the united states they
can basically fabricate and this is
something i believe is going to happen
in the united states is there going to
be a short-term food supply shortage
it's not because we don't have ax we
don't have enough food we don't have
access to food because like a famine or
well there's going to be famines moving
forward okay explain that well right now
we're basically there was a fertilizer
shortage a prohibition against
fertilizer and this is part of the the
global movement this basically this big
global industrial food shift that i've
been talking about this has been planned
for a while
and so what we've done is there's a
nitrogen shortage nitrogen shortage
fertilizer shortage you have fertilizer
shortage you have a grain shortage you
have a war in ukraine and russia well
guess who create creates 33 of our the
global grain russia and ukraine reason
that basically i think that russia is
not having lopes because ukraine owns a
lot of that wheat a lot of that grain
so you're having a global basically
shortage of grain that plays out over
time if you don't have grain you don't
feed livestock you don't feed people so
what happens with that and you look at
the history of man if you have a
pandemic what else comes with the
pandemic
a famine what comes with the famine
migration
so i see what what's about to take place
is we're going to have a famine that
causes migration where that starts i
don't know is the famine going to be in
africa probably is it going to be in
asia possibly and once that happens
you're going to start seeing migration
happening to europe again so when when
something like this plays out uh it's
kind of like monetary policy in the
economy a little bit like uh we have
high inflation right now right right uh
highest has been in 40 years why well
monetary policy is a pretty big part of
it yeah there's also supply chain
disruptions government lockdowns the
geopolitical conflicts like there's
multiple things that feed into it
if we see
famine anywhere in the world
multiple things that feed into it some
of it is what i'll call kind of more the
macro trends around the way the food's
been treated seeds and a lot of things
we've been talking about some of it's
also just like fertilizer shortage yeah
right and then also some of it seems to
be uh if you're not able to actually
have the wheat hardest uh harvest or the
grain harvest uh that you normally would
in russia and ukraine right then you
can't export it if you can't export it
then there's a shortage and it just
throws the whole system kind of out of
whack right uh
the positive side of that is if it
occurs uh hopefully we can get back on
track after you know one or two seasons
and kind of everything will be okay but
that remains kind of an open question of
like how bad is the pain it seems like
right in the short term and then how
quickly can we get back on track uh once
some of these issues are solved yeah and
that's a really good way to look at that
that's a good breakdown because a lot of
people think everything's instantaneous
you know we live in the high time
preference way in which we think
whenever you have that grain shortage
that takes time to play out and so it's
not automatically seen and so you'll see
touch points of things that are not
available anymore you know and by saying
that it's like okay whenever i was on
harvest i quit harvest early last year i
said i got to start writing this because
i knew there was going to be a grain
shortage this year i knew that this was
coming down so i wanted to get the
message out there because all the
ranchers that i spoke to in the very
beginning especially said we have to
make this happen in 2022. we have to get
people aware now so they can basically
be prepared i think us as americans
above and beyond anybody has a way that
we can empower ourselves right now
during times of mass prohibition there
should be times of mass innovation and i
think that's what we're positioned to do
as far as the beef initiative and the
ranchers that have come on board we're
giving that option we're not thinking
about food insecurity right now
everybody that's come through the beef
initiative as far as a producer rancher
they're thriving right now because that
consumer demand is being changed and not
you know i haven't talked about the beef
initiative and how much beef we're
selling because well
you got to look at volume what can you
supply i don't want to go out there and
larp and say hey look at me look at me
it's not about likes you know i grew my
twitter channel in bitcoin twitter and i
did it very slowly because every bit of
my growth was dependent on what we could
supply to the consumer and now that we
have the processing centers our volume
is increasing 10 poll well now
here we are talking and that way i can
control what we can supply and i'm very
confident now that we can supply to like
i say you know
uh 10 times more than we were in the
beginning how does it work people people
show up and they say hey i want healthy
beef where i know where it came from uh
and you all are essentially aggregating
suppliers
and producers and saying we can uh
provide you access kind of market access
right to the uh the beef itself what
what has happened you know in in you
let's talk about bitcoin you know and
you know the beef initiative and i tell
this to everybody the beef initiative
basically is the most firm stance in
integrity that you can find in beef
right now in the united states and in
the world and if you don't believe me
just try me we've we've put a lot of
time into that it is about integrity of
food and this is the number one thing
that we have to look at so by saying
that we built out the technology stack
and i always wanted to give the option
of you can buy in fiat or you can buy
one bitcoin and so what that took was
educating ranchers and everything cole
bolton was one of the first ones we
approached like i said before
and he'd kind of dabbled in bitcoin a
little bit but we built out our
technology stack and we've developed
these really good relationships with
oshie with ibex we used open node and
you know we used everything that's out
there right now man our technology stack
is foolproof right now it's doing really
well and so by doing that you can go to
the beef initiative right now in 48
states in the united states and you can
buy boxes of beef
by saying that well you can also go to
oshie and if you're in texas or a
surrounding state you can buy a half a
cow or a quarter of a cow
so you can basically source your beef
right now through the beef initiative
anywhere in the united states okay
that's our major supplier is cole bolton
of knc cattle okay you get jason out
there in colorado well he's part of the
beef initiative too he just likes to do
the western slope of colorado and so
everybody realizes that when they go
find him in the beef initiative because
they can search for him under the
producers well people that are local to
him well they're buying from him
and now we're bringing in holy cow of
west texas they do grass fed and grass
finished now we're going to go into a
subscription model to where every month
you can go through there and you can
basically have a box shipped to you you
can from cole bolton or k and c cattle
holy cow
outside of lubbock texas and then we're
bringing in somebody from western
colorado scott hawk of sacred farms so
yeah the producers are coming in and
we're giving them that technology
stacked where they can accept fiat or
bitcoin and so by doing that we have
over i think 50 to 60 producers that are
listed under in the platform under
producers well now we're going to start
hitting every one of those states and
we're going to let them do the case
study that we did with cole bolton now
we can do it washington state we can do
it in florida we can do it in maine
california and all these producers get
to come in coal gets to look at texas
again and then all these other producers
get to start serving their communities
like they want to that way we have a lot
of different options maybe you do want
to get your beef from texas you have
that option maybe you want to get it
from florida where you're going to have
that option
and so as you know i spread the word the
the producers are coming in i go meet
with them and i see what their protocol
is
you know does it match the beef
initiative standards our standard is far
better than the usda stamp usda staff
can say yeah we're the usda well so what
i don't care we're the beef initiative
and i'll talk to anybody about how we
raise and steward and process and
deliver beef and it's the standard to be
well you guys start to put stickers on
stuff so we will there's a process that
you go through that because we have to
play by the rules right and we want to
know the law better than the law knows
itself so at one point in time the beef
initiative will have a snap yeah and you
can put that on and people can look at
not only the usda but yeah now it's more
of a state of mind it's a marketing
thing in a way that's you know kind of
grassroots marketing you know kind of
information exchange that builds some
trust
but over a period of time we'll say we
are the brand here you can trust us and
people will go hell yeah man that's the
beef initiative yeah when we think about
a lot of the food supply one of the last
things i want to talk about uh is uh the
testosterone levels yeah have fallen off
a cliff yeah um the latest stats that
i've seen are uh somebody born in 2020
has about 50 percent of the testosterone
of someone born in 20 uh 2000 20-year
kind of difference 50 drop in
testosterone uh how much of that is just
pure food versus other things you think
well it's
let's start off by saying this your skin
is your second stomach okay okay you
look at that and you look at things like
plastics
phthalates and you look at hormones in
children and you look at delivery of
minerals and vitamins and you look what
your skin basically takes in how many
people go through and take a shower and
you know soap and shampoo with all kinds
of chemicals before they ever even eat
anything
okay and you look at children what do
they eat well their first you know maybe
they took a shower last night or they
took a shower this morning well they
already got all those chemicals their
skin's already basically digesting
everything it has to go through their
blood systems well now they're they're
eating food now that has no protein in
it that's what's dropping these
testosterone levels and going back to
the doctors that i do work with this is
this not one doctor everybody that's
come through the beef initiative because
of what we're doing because we're basing
nutrition to kids is they're saying that
yeah most teenagers now their
testosterone levels to your point is
around 200. it should be about 12 to
1400.
okay and that is insane it's well
it's
it's destroying a generation of young
men that's what it's doing
and you look at the children but now
let's look at teenagers you know let's
look at guys in their 20s they don't
have the testosterone of me
you know they don't and they don't know
why
if you go to a doctor and say test my uh
testosterone that doctor's gonna say why
why do you want your testosterone
checked and you look back at the social
engineering oh well that's masculinity
oh that's you know testosterone is rage
you know and they talk about that all
the time you know and so part of it is
social engineering people not
understanding how important testosterone
level is and how dangerous it is this to
to to engineer
a decrease in uh hormone levels in
children you know from testosterone to
estrogen whenever you're having little
boys come in and they're basically
having estrogen and they're growing
breast
and they should not be growing breast
they're not going into puberty when they
should be going into puberty and you you
look at the manipulation in the
engineering of
of the delivery of the minerals and
vitamins and everything that should be
okay as a society that we should be
paying attention to
we're not paying attention to it
and parents don't know how to pay
attention to it and when they do try to
pay attention to it you know centralized
media basically makes it a non-issue
when it's one of the biggest issues you
have yeah and when you
think of the testosterone is that
water playing to it as well like that's
one of the big things i hear is you know
i drink a lot of liquids out of water
bottles and there are people you know
that's one of the big things that they
push on and i'm like oh [ __ ] maybe i
should stop doing that like what do you
think about water versus the just the
proteins and animal proteins i think of
course water is the substance of life
you know you can go you can you know i
fast a lot you know one time i did a
10-day fast i can go 10 days without
eating
can i go ten tails without water no so i
look at it to your question i think it's
hand in hand it really is you know
having clean water is is basically just
top of mind just as much as protein is
and that's what i you know that's how i
live and of course we shouldn't be
drinking out of plastic bottles right
but you know we we do the best we can
right now and you know you ease into
but you know that the water consumption
and the flow of the body is extremely
important because it cleans it cleanses
but then again the plastics in which we
do
expose ourselves to
does end up that we have to process that
too yeah so you know if you're if you're
consuming a lot of you know um [ __ ] food
you know there's a lot of plastics in
our food now there's a lot of glass like
glyphosate in our food there's so many
chemicals in our food that you know the
one thing that you should do is i do a
48 hour bone broth fast okay what is
that what it is is you you get a
grass-fed beef grass-finished beef and
you basically make a bone broth out of
that and you do
i call it a reset
and what you do is you only consume
water and bone broth for like 48 hours
well it gives your system a reset you
get to say whoa hold up here
i'm gonna clear up my mind a little bit
i'm gonna clear up my body a little bit
and i'm gonna flush it out you know i'm
gonna flush it out with water and then
i'm gonna deliver
pure animal protein and nutrition
through bone broth if you look at and
you dissect a cow down you look how
valuable the bone is
the marrow
everything within the cow that we
as people do not understand anymore what
you're going to do is you're going to
give your body a reset it's going to
give your mind a break
once again referring back to doctors
some functional medicine doctors
especially they're telling their parents
their their patience i'm not going to
talk to you until you do a 48 hour bone
broth fast because what what you have
right now a lot of people's brains are
inflamed they're inflamed by eating
overly processed food acetyls high
fructose corn syrup you have children
coming in to the doctors as well with
fatty liver disease that used to be a
problem of a man that drank all of his
life in his 70s now we have children 5
to 11 that are coming in and need liver
transplants because the high fructose
corn syrup because of seed oils because
everything that we're feeding them and
of course they're not drinking enough
water and they're getting too much of
those pesticides those plastics and
everything so we have to look like we
have to become our own filters yeah um
we've been talking today obviously the
beef initiative is very focused on
delivering animal proteins and making
sure that's the healthiest possible
somebody who's blown up on the internet
recently is liver king what are your
take on on this guy who's eating bone
marrow and livers and uh you know looks
like a herculean statue uh says it's all
natural uh what what's your general
taste it's a 100 natural man that guy
will go out there you know and he will
eat a full liver that's raw
and he'll eat it from a grass-fed
grass-finished cow
and what he's doing
i don't want to say it's overreach well
it's overstep for a lot of people but i
see what his point is
it's like this is where you get your
power from you know he does he looks and
freakishly you know big and built and
just everything about him
but what he's making a statement of is
that he knows what vitamins and minerals
are
he's making you look at him and he's
saying i eat bones this is where the
minerals are and you need to pay
attention it's not in that box of cereal
that says it's loaded with vitamins and
minerals but all it is is sugar you know
so he's making a statement on that level
but if you go through i have never met
not one time in my life
somebody that's east like he does or
close to that has health problems
in that is basically you know somebody
that suffers from being overfed and
nutritionally starved everybody that you
look that basically has a consumption
model based on his extremities basically
his extremes
you're gonna find people that are much
more clear in the mind much more clear
in the body much more clear in their
spirit it's just something that you you
do notice i think that's what he's
trying to make a point of yeah he
probably didn't start out like that but
his success lies in his communication
and his representation yeah that makes
uh makes a ton of sense can you overeat
meat
yeah your body's only going to digest so
much protein it will extract the rest
yeah well i i guess part of it is uh if
you think of you know people being fat
right uh because they eat more calories
than uh then they burn right uh to some
degree i think with meat most people say
like you eat enough and your body just
says hey no no more yeah we're fine
right and it almost prevents you from
overeating in the way that you know if
you're eating kind of empty calories for
example uh it does feel like uh that
it's much harder i guess to become obese
yeah if uh if your body just literally
won't let you consume more calories
because it's satiation yeah well you
look at you eat pure animal protein
you know you're gonna die you have to
digest less you know what are you doing
well it's mostly just vitamins and
minerals there's not a lot of you know
impurities in that and so your body will
say hey cool you know we're good i'm
getting energy from what you're feeding
me i'm gonna let you know whenever you
don't have to eat as much right whenever
you're eating heavily processed food and
all those chemicals that we talked about
all the different ingredients the fake
commodities everything in that food
doesn't matter what the package says you
know
mostly with our consumption models in
our food industry right now you're
having to eat every four hours you look
at how we've marketed and everything
since the the food pyramid let's say you
know the pizza you know you're eating
pizza you're eating the best food in the
world you got everything you know you
got all the food groups what that has
led us to be is basically our bodies are
starving
okay we're over fed and undernourished
okay we're nutritionally starved in a
way
by being overfed what we mean is we're
consuming so much food that our bodies
don't know what to do with that
what we're consuming what does your body
do with something that it doesn't know
what to do with turns it into a fat cell
for defense
and so what we're doing that's how we're
getting on this basically this road map
of you know obesity which we are as a
nation and the world is turning into
is because our bodies don't know when to
say our minds don't know when to say
stop
because we're we're basically feeding it
something that's not working out it's
like man this is not this uh and people
you look at food now is a drug
okay food is medicine medicine is food
okay you look at it like that well now
food the way that we consume it as far
as the industrial food complex it's
nothing more than a drug
okay my father was a counselor for 25
years on chemical dependency
so i've always talked to him about that
and we look at food now and you look at
somebody that tries to go through a fast
like that and they haven't eaten in
eight hours and they're used to eating
every four hours they're used to getting
that snack you know whatever that snack
is you know they're always consuming
it's never stopping when you get that
same person you say stop okay well
they're gonna go through a form of okay
being an alcoholic okay is it whenever
you get off alcohol and you're a true
alcoholic you're going through a detox
well alcohol is nothing more than sugar
okay you look at arc food consumption
now in the united states of america
heavily processed most of it is just
sugar so you get somebody that's used to
eating that consumption model they're
going through a form of detox that is
scary to them and they don't feel right
what is their comfort go back to the
source just like an addict does
and so we've turned food into such a
powerful drug that a lot of people don't
understand it nor basically do they want
to even go there because they have to
look in that accountability mirror yeah
and
it literally just comes down to uh
you're putting things in your body
whether it's medicine or food right yeah
your body's going to react and
i think that your you know macro point
around just the food intelligence
people don't know uh what they're
putting in their bodies no right
even if they're good and they have good
intentions man and that's why i always
tell people this is not a judgment man
we're all victims of it you know we all
eat like crap at times we have in our
lives man we're all in this together man
this is not something pointing to you
saying you're doing the wrong diet
program you know oh kato over paleo or
vegan over vegetarianism
it's the beefing initially because i'm
from freaking texas man you know but
what it's really about is pure food
again
and if we can look at that and say man
that's all i really need to do i don't
need to get on this 12-month diet
program that starts on january 2nd we're
gonna have that day extra where i have
to really think about it and then kick
in and then i [ __ ] here i am eating
donuts again on february 2nd
so we don't have to play that game
anymore what you have to do is basically
be intentional saying man i'm just going
to get back to some pure food again and
i'm going to take a different route this
time i uh i usually eat pretty healthy
but i'm going to admit to you i had a i
had a cookie last night
i saw it i said i should look at you
hell yeah and i knew that i was like man
i'm eating unhealthy but like whatever
right and i i do think uh uh everyone
does it you don't right of course man
you can't eat how guilty i feel when i
eat some ice cream man i was like
somebody's looking at my ass
but but but i i do believe that uh you
know there's plenty of fads and diets
like all this stuff is uh everyone's
looking for the shortcut yeah but but
the overall message of just uh one
understanding what you put in your body
but also two uh just eating real food
yeah i mean if you just start there like
just eat real food not the processed
stuff
for most people that's a pretty big
improvement it really is and like i said
when i first started writing about this
i said man this is daunting where do you
start a lot of people start mid-stream
of trying to make change what i'm asking
people is get down to the source of the
seed of the solution but first you have
to understand the source of the seed of
the issue and there there's so many
things that we can talk about and what
you just said made me think about the
first conversation i had with cole and
everybody's like oh your beef is too
expensive you want a bed guess what now
our beef is just basically less
expensive than the supermarket is right
now or the same price but the value okay
let's talk about the value of course
it's going to be the taste of course
it's going to be the nutrition
everything else
what else is what is the value of that
purchase of having that market access
and that consumption will your medical
bills go down your insurance changes
that's what the ranchers want people to
know it's like hey you don't have to
look at it this way perception is your
reality where your perception needs to
change about buying pure animal protein
in a different way if you're going to
compare somebody like cole bolton or
jason rick or justin trammell to the
supermarket you've already lost man
you're you're it's apples and oranges
right you can't make that comparison and
what you need to do is really understand
that your beef that you're getting
delivered to your doorstep
is basically in line with the pricing
models of you basically going down to
your local supermarket now because how
they are manipulating the beef industry
to where you the consumer and the
rancher the ones that are paying the
prices my takeaways from today are eat
real food uh know what you put in your
body and uh when you go to the grocery
store stay on the outside don't go in
don't go inside all right right so i
feel like that's a pretty good takeaway
for most people yeah yeah and you know i
have to say it's like go to
freakingbeefinitiative.com man seriously
yeah well i was gonna ask where can we
send people if people uh either want to
learn more about
what they're eating and all that or if
they want to actually order uh healthier
beef and go right to the ranchers where
should we send it well what i tell
everybody there's a lot of different
ways you can do it what i'm pushing
right now because you know it's time
we're ready to go into fall especially
because i think there will be some food
insecurity in this nation is like
develop your market access the best
place to start is through the beef
initiative right now you know people
will say well what about places like
butcher box or whole foods it's not the
same man it's not the same beef it's not
aged i mean everything about it we are
basically right now the type of uh
capacity that we have and what we can
provide as far as that pure animal
protein just beefiness calm and you can
purchase your boxes through us
you know that the rancher you know me
now you know everything that you have
you have a new market access for you
know your consumption model that's the
best place to start
initiative.com
and then if you don't want to buy from
us then do a search on our producer page
say hey i got these guys in missouri i
got this person i found you know in
idaho we've got them basically coming in
from every state and say hey man they're
right down the road from me
and so as what we're doing with the beef
initiative we are we're building
communities what we're trying to do we
want every community now
that's how we win this game we don't do
it with a 300 or a 600 million dollar
processing center that's owned by the
process or the producers no we go
through there and we put establish a
processing center in a market demand and
a consumer demand on a community based
level yeah and that's what we're having
a lot of success and it really is taking
you know taking shape absolutely we're
here with some people to find you if
they want to either talk to you more
about some of the stuff or they just
want to follow along as you keep
building well we have a lot of touch
points now we've created a new media
company that we're going to do audio
docu series on twitter that's at tx slim
media and then of course my sub stack
which started it all is
texasslam.substack.com that's where i
sent you and that's where you can read
from the very beginning as far as the
harvest of deception i read it twice
well i read the first time and i said
hey i gotta go back there's a lot in
there right but but uh um and then your
twitter account yeah it's at modern
t-man and then of course we have the
beef initiative which is at beef
initiative
and one thing i want to point out is you
know doing these con these i call them a
summit now and we're having our next one
in white oak pastures that i spoke of
and this september 16 through uh 17th
and 18th we have will harris himself we
have adam curry's going to be speaking
there we have people have a heritage
woman series we have the ranchers coming
in we have bitcoiners that are going to
be speaking matt o'dell and several
other bitcoiners spoke so we're giving
education across the board they're
interactive conferences events and now
it's basically a food intelligence
summit is what it is so we're only
selling 100 tickets and we want people
to show up and we've had basically that
many people and whenever they leave
these summits their their their lives
are changing and so that's why how we're
growing is because it's grassroots yeah
and you know it's happening so you can
go to the beef initiative.com website
and you can look at that and you can buy
your tickets there as well
we're gonna have more of these summits
uh we've actually now we're gonna have
two in australia i'm heading to
australia the end of january this is
just not a texas thing this is just not
a national this is a global thing
uh we're gonna have a headquarters in
tennessee and nashville
there at bitcoin park we've got a
headquarters in colorado out at rick's
ranches
we have a headquarters in canyon texas
and then down there at the processing
center uh south of austin we're building
out these note we're building nodes
and we're building beef nodes and
everywhere we go building a beef node is
going to be a bitcoin node
and you know it's happening naturally
it's happening open source we're
crowdsourcing we're crowdfunding and you
know everybody's coming in and they're
starting to realize this isn't some
stupid fiat marketing plan man you know
it really isn't this is something that
is is grass roots it really is that's
what's been exciting about this is that
how much the bitcoin community
has caught on how much the ranching
community has caught on you get a
bitcoin or what would you say is the
bitcoiners are going to orange peel the
ranchers the ranch pill the ranchers are
ranch killing the bitcoiners
that's great it is though it's a perfect
balance because everybody's you show up
in one of these summits there's no
strangers everybody gets along and
they're all talking and they're all
making these relationships
and man we've got stu i got to go up to
i'm going to go up to idaho i'm going up
to wyoming after the the georgia summit
and then like i said i'm going to
australia i'm in talks with uh you know
talking with the us cattlemen's
association right now this is happening
and we're going to punch hard really
forward really hard right now i love it
well texas slim i appreciate the
conversation i learned a bunch today and
we'll definitely do it again in the
future palm thanks for having me man
appreciate it